GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE HEARING.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO PRACTICE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE. WE
ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCHING
PARTICIPATION THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE ALSO REQUIRING THE
MASS BE WORN PHYSICAL DISTANCE
IN BE MAINTAINED BY EVERYONE
PRESENT HERE IN THE ROOM. BUT
THE VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. IF
YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. TODAY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR TWO WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTENTION OF STAFF AND LIMITED
NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO
WE CAN MAINTAIN APPROPRIATE
SPACING. THERE ARE ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCE THE PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL. FOR THOSE OF
YOU HERE IN THE ROOM. I'VE BEEN
A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL PLEASE LISTEN FOR MY
PROMPT TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN YOUR SEATS.
PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE USING
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH WE WITNESS
CONTEST EACH WITH ANY WITNESS
CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
WHEN THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOUR TESTIFYING ON BEGIN THEIR
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCASTS ON YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF ANY. IF ANY OF
YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL YOU'LL REMAIN
ON A LIVE LINE WILL NEED TO
MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOUR CALL
TO SPEAK ON. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATOR
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE NINE THREE ONE NINE.
THREE NINE FIVE EIGHT AND MY
STUFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO
HELP. I ALSO WANT TO KNOW THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
CONTINUE USING METHODS TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE STILL FACE. NOW
LET'S COVER THE GROUND RULES
FOR APPROPRIATE CONDUCT.
ASSEMBLY HAS EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS COMMITTEE
AND FLOOR PROCEEDINGS IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS. CONTACT THE
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THE HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE. REMOVING
MASK AND REFUSING TO PUT IT
BACK ON. TALKING ARE MAKING
LOUD NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE SPEAKING
LONGER THAN TIME ALLOTTED.
EXTENDED DISCUSSION ON MATTERS
NOT RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF
THE HEARING OR THE BILL IN A
DISRUPTIVE ACCESS. TO IT TO
ADDRESS THE IN A DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT I WILL TAKE THE
FOLLOWING STEPS. SEVEN
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR HEARING
PROCESS I WOULD DIRECT THEM TO
STOP AND WARNED THEM TO
CONTINUE DISRUPTIONS MAY RESULT
REMOVAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. I WILL ALSO DOCUMENT
ON THE RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL
INVOLVED AND THE NATURE OF THE
DESTRUCTIVE CONDUCT I MAY.
TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE
HEARING. YEAH THE CONDUCT NOT.
I WILL RE THE ASSISTANCE OF THE
SARGE IN ESCORTING THE
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. WE HAVE TWENTY ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA TODAY. FOUR OF
THOSE ITEMS ARE PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. OUR CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSISTS OF THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHU COOLEY. NUMBER SIX. HI AB
EIGHT FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER. AB FIFTEEN ASSIST ME
ITEM FIFTEEN AB NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD. IDM
NUMBER TWENTY AB FIFTEEN NINETY
TWO BY THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. ONE ITEM HAS BEEN
PULLED ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB
ONE ONE FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM. IN ADDITION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM WERE PRESENT ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB. TEN NINETY
TWO ON BEHALF OF IT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN. WE'LL HEAR ALL
OTHER BILLS IN THE ORDER SHOWN
ON OUR AGENDA. WE WILL TAKE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FOR EACH BILL. THESE
WITNESSES WILL HAVE THREE
MINUTES EACH TO PROVIDE THE
TESTIMONY ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME THE ORGANIZATION AND THE
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY. ALL
SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION MAY PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN ANY ORDER. WE
DON'T HAVE A POOR. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR- YOU KNOW. OKAY I'LL
READ NOT HAVE A QUORUM AS OF
YET SO WILL OPERATE AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. OUR FIRST BILL IS
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWO FIFTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU.
WELCOME MR CHIU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES AB
TWO FIFTEEN SIX TO IMPROVE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR CITIES WHERE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT HAS BEEN
UNDERPERFORMING TO ADDRESS A
HOUSING CRISIS ARE LEGISLATURE
IN RECENT YEARS HAS MADE CLEAR
THAT HOUSING PRODUCTION IS A
PRIORITY BY OVERHAULING THE
HOUSING ELEMENT PROCESS TO
ENSURE THE LOCAL POLICIES ALIGN
WITH THE STATE'S GOAL OF
SUPPORTING HOUSING PRODUCTION
WHILE PROVIDING CITIES AND
COUNTIES THE FLEXIBILITY TO
FIND STRATEGIES THAT WORK. THIS
BILL WOULD MAINTAIN THAT LOCAL
FLEXIBILITY BUT ENSURE THAT
LOCAL PLANS ARE EFFECTIVE IN
PRODUCING HOUSING IT INCREASES
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THREE WAYS
FIRST REQUIRE CITIES TO HAVE A
MID CYCLE CONSULTATION WITH
EACH CD IF OVERALL OR FOR A
HOUSING PRODUCTION HAS BEEN
UNDER THE REGIONAL AVERAGE AT
THE CONSULTATION CITIES IN EACH
CITY WILL WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE
SURE THE HOUSING ELEMENT IS
BEING IMPLEMENTED APPROPRIATELY
AND REVISING. STRATEGIES THAT
ARE NOT WORKING. THE SECOND WAY
IS AT THE BILL REQUIRES A CITY
WHERE PRODUCTION HAS BEEN
SUBSTANTIALLY BELOW THE
REGIONAL AVERAGE TO DROP LOCAL
POLICIES THAT ENABLE IT TO
ACHIEVE EIGHT CITIES PRO
HOUSING DESIGNATION. LASTLY THE
BUILDING ADDS THE HOUSING
CRISIS ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
TO THE LIST OF STATE HOUSING
LAWS THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
CAN ENFORCE. THESE THREE
STRATEGIES WILL BETTER ENSURE
THE ALIGNMENT OF STATE AND
LOCAL GOALS FOR THE CREATION OF
HOUSING. AT ALL INCOME LEVELS
AND THIS BILL SUPPORTEDBY WIDE
COALITION OF HOUSING ADVOCATES.
OF AFFORDABLE AS WELL AS
HOUSING INDUSTRY INTERESTS AND
WITH THAT WILL TURN IT OVER TO
A WITNESS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IN YOUR WITNESS MAY SPEAK. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MARINO WHITE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
C. H. C. AS IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSINGADVOCACY ORGANIZATION.
FOCUSED ON THE PRODUCTION
PRESERVATION OF HOUSING
AFFORDABLE TO LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND WE ARE PLEASED
TO SPONSOR AB TWO FIFTEEN.
WHICH INCREASES THE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF CITIES TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENTS ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED.
AND ARE EFFECTIVE AT
FACILITATING HOUSING
PRODUCTION. BUILDING ON THE
EFFORTS OF AB SEVENTY TWO FROM
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH WE ALSO
CO SPONSORED AB TWO FIFTEEN
TAKES ANOTHER IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARDS ENSURING EVERY REGION.
IS MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS
MEETING THEIR HOUSING GOALS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU NOTED AB
TWO FIFTEEN MAINTAINS THAT
LOCAL FLEXIBILITY. BUT
INCREASES OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE
THAT LOCAL PLANS ARE EFFECTIVE
IN PRODUCING HOUSING. THIS
LEGISLATION WILL NOT ONLY
IMPROVE THE STATE'S ABILITY TO
KEEP TABS ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION IT WILL ALSO OFFER
TIMELY TARGETED SUPPORT TO
JURISDICTIONS FALLING BEHIND
THEIR HOUSING GOALS TARGETS.
HELPING EVERY COMMUNITY STAY ON
TRACK TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CALIFORNIA NEEDS. FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE JUST
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
OTHER. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I
DON'T SEE IT. ON THE ON. NO
OPERATE DO WE HAVE ANYONE. IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ONLINE. AB
TWO FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TEN LINES
IN Q. OR TRYING THREE EIGHTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT THREE
EIGHT TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANKS FOR FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS FOR EIGHTEEN
YEARS TWO ONE FIVE FOUR FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT THREE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
KIMBERLY DONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILLS THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. THREE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY RUN
Q. BY THREE NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE MATTER
THAT WAY HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BEAT SAND HILL
PROPERTY'S THE COMPANY ALTHOUGH
THERE CANDY PARTNERS THANK YOU
A- AT AT HOME AND THE PLANNING
AND URBAN RESEARCH AT THE- ALL
IN OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ABOUT A LEADERSHIP GROUP
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
I'M THREE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MICHAEL IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION OUR
SPORT AND SPORT. THANK YOU.
FIVE FOUR FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS KELLY CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU FIVE FOUR
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS CAITLIN
JOHNSON THE POLITICAL SOLUTION
ON BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK NINE THREE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS CAROL SCHOOL HOME FROM MY
MAKE LOCAL FOUR HUNDRED. THE
PORT. THE BILL. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARE AGUIAR-CURRY. GO AHEAD
MISTER LANG. THIS IS CHRIS LEE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION-
FIRST I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
WE DON'T OPPOSE EACH CD
OVERSIGHT SPECIFICALLY WE TAKE
NO ISSUE WITH SECTION ONE OF
THE BILL REGARDING THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL REFERRALS RELATED TO
NON COMPLIANCE WITH HOUSING
CRISIS ACTOR TWENTY NINETEEN WE
HAVEN'T OBJECTED TO INCREASING
FUNDING FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND OVERSIGHT FOR
MADE CD. AND WE KNOW THAT EACH
CD ALREADY HAD SIGNIFICANT
AUTHORITY TO OVERSEE HOUSING
ELEMENT ADOPTION IMPLEMENTATION
AND LOCAL AGENCIES THAT ARE OUT
OF COMPLIANCE WITH THESE
REQUIREMENTS CAN BE SUBJECT TO
SIGNIFICANT FINES WHAT WE DO
OBJECT TO WITH THIS BILL AND
THE NEW PROCESS CREATED FOR
THIS MID CYCLE CONSULTATION WE
THINK THIS IS REDUNDANT OF THE
EXISTING AUTHORITY THAT EACH CD
ALREADY HAS BUT WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED THAT IT'S POORLY
TARGETED- WE FEEL THAT
ESPECIALLY IN THE
UNINCORPORATED COUNTY AREAS
WHICH TEND TO BE LESS.
ECONOMICALLY ROBUST IN HAVE
WEAKER HOUSING MARKETS THEY'RE
LIKELY TO BE CAUGHT UP IN THIS
PROCESS JUST BY VIRTUE OF THAT
WEAKER MARKET THAT EXIST OUT
THERE RATHER THAN FOCUSING THE
OVERSIGHT ON JURISDICTIONS THAT
MAY BE ACTIVELY OBSTRUCTING
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT FOR OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR
OBLIGATIONS WE ALSO WERE TO
OBJECT TO THE REQUIREMENTS- OF.
ATTAINING THE PRO HOUSING-
POLICY DESIGNATION BY EIGHT CD
THIS WHOLE PROGRAM WAS SET UP
ON A PREMISE OF BEING AN
INCENTIVE BASED ON STRUCTURE
AND NOW IT'S GOING TO BE
CREATED AS A MANDATE FOR THIS
SUBSET OF JURISDICTIONS BEFORE
WE EVEN KNOW WHAT THE- POLICIES
LOOK LIKE THE REGULATIONS FOR
THIS PROGRAM HAVE NOT YET BEEN
RELEASED ON THAT ALSO CREATES
OBVIOUSLY A PRACTICAL CONCERN
FOR US. WHEN WE COMMENTED BACK
IN TWENTY NINETEEN ON THE SRT
OF A ROUGH DRAFT THAT WAS PUT
OUT BY THE DEPARTMENT WE
IDENTIFIED CONCERNS ABOUT
MAKING SURE IT'S SUCH A PROGRAM
WAS GOING TO BE APPLICABLES
ESPECIALLY FOR RURAL IN
UNINCORPORATED JURISDICTIONS-
AND CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
CONCERNS GIVEN THAT WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THE FINAL RULES. SO FOR
THOSE TWO REASONS- WE I
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITE TODAY.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
OTHERS IN A WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BY
THREE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS JASON NINE LEAGUE
CALIFORNIA CITIES- WE ARE ALSO
IN OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE
FOR MANY OF THE SAME REASONS
THAT MR. LEE SPOKE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I MEAN BROKEN
COALITION STAMPING NAY.
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THREE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE FIVE
SEVEN. YOU HEAR ME. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES I AM THE CONTROVERSY
GETS FROM SOCIAL EQUAL
EDUCATION AND I AM CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND JUST
TO KEEP IN MIND THAT A LOT OF
THE TIME THE BILL AND THOSE WHO
WE ARE THREE OPERATOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I'M GOING
TO TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE IF YOU
DON'T MIND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SECRETARY AGUIAR-CURRY HERE
PRESIDENT LACKEY BECAUSE OF.
THAT THE PRESIDENT LOW WILL
PRESENT BOERNER HORVATH HELLO
THIS YEAR WELL MOST PRESENT
THREE OF US. ROBERT RIVAS YEAH
ROBERT RIVAS PRESIDENT WILL
TELL YOU VOEPEL PRESSING ONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SECRETARY
WILL CONTINUE ON- ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS- TO FOR THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR- AB. EIGHT TO
FIFTEEN. I SEE NO COURT NO
QUESTIONS- CONSUME SOME
ENTERTAINMENT SHOULD. WE HAVE A
PROMOTION MIND MISTER REAVIS
AND MOLD A SECOND BY MISTER
RAMOS. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I WANTED
TO SAY IS THAT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FOR IT
OBVIOUSLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU I
APPRECIATE YOUR DEDICATION TO
THE ISSUE THAT THIS BILL IS
SEEKING TO ADD ANOTHER LAYER OF
COUNT ACCOUNTABILITY. TO THE
RENEWAL PROCESS I KNOW YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
INTERESTED PARTIES MOVING
FORWARD AND I'M PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE TODAY
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU SECRETARY. PLEASE HURRY. HI
IRAQI. FIVE NINETY FIVE BLUE. I
FURTHERMORE THAT ROMMEL'S FOR
ALMOST FIVE FROM THREE WITH
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS
ARTICLE RIGHT RIGHT SIX ZERO
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. ARE SIX
ZERO AND WAIT FOR THE MISSING.
YOUR BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
PERMIS THIS. OKAY LET'S MR- OF-
A LEVEL FOR ME TO GO WITH I HAD
A NUMBER EIGHT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON WHICH IS TO NOW. AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR ITEM EIGHT
WE WILL. BUT I. THE MOTION NINE
BLOCKING. PROCEED WITH YOUR A-
CROWDED AGENDA I'LL BE SURE
WITH MY COMMENTS TODAY THANK
YOU FOR MOVING THE BILL ON
SECOND A GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
MADAM CHAIR I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
WHICH WILL ALLOW QUALIFIED
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS TO
BE- TO EFFECTIVELY USE THE
STREAMLINED APPROVAL PROCESS
ESTABLISHED IN PREVIOUS-
LEGISLATION FROM TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. WHAT IT DOES DO IS
IT MAKES CLARIFYING CHANGES TO
ADDRESS THE EMERGENT ISSUES
FIRST TO CLARIFY IS THAT A
THREE YEAR SHOT CLOCK FOR
DEVELOPMENT FOR MODIFICATIONS
APPROVALS PAUSED WHEN THE CITY
THROUGH THE PROJECT SECOND IT
SPECIFIES THAT A PROJECT MUST
ONLY COMPLY WITH OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS THAT WERE IN PLACE
WHEN THE PROJECT WAS APPROVED
AND LASTLY AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR MAKES TRAPPING AMENDMENTS
TO PREVIOUS SB THIRTY FIVE
RELATED BILLS. SO WITH THAT I-
DO HAVE A WITNESS MICHAEL LANE-
WAS SERVICES GO BAY AREA
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION YOU'LL BE BRIEF IN
HIS COMMENTS AS WELL GREAT
THANK YOU MISTER LANE WELCOME.
THE MANAGER MEMBERS MICHAEL
LINGUIST BURKE SB THIRTY FIVE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IS THAT
TREMENDOUS PUT INTO THE
PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. STREAMLINED APPROVALS
FOR PROPERTIES ON SITES THAT
HELP TO BRING NEW HOMES ONLINE
MORE QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
OPERATE AS WITH ALL MAJOR
LANDMARK LEGISLATION THERE IS A
NEED FOR CLARIFICATIONS AND
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP TO IMPLEMENT
THE LAW AND ADVANCE THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATURE. AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR WORDS WILL ENSURE
THE PROJECT SPONSORS DID NOT
LOSE THE BENEFITS. UNDER SB
THIRTY FIVE DUE TO LITIGATION.
THE BILL ALSO VERIFIED STATE
LOCAL LAWS. IN EFFECT THE TIME
WHEN THE ORIGINAL DEVELOPMENT
APPLICATION WAS SUBMITTED SHALL
ALSO APPLY TO SUBSEQUENT
PERMITS. IT CLARIFICATIONS WILL
ENSURE THE HOUSE APPROVAL
STREAMLINING FUNCTIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE INTENDED. AND WE
URGE MY BOOK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR MUCH MISTER LANE I
DON'T WOULDN'T IN SOME.
OPERATOR THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK. GOING OPERATOR OR
POLITICS YOU WISH. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE ABOUT SIX IN Q.
OR SALIVA THREE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE SIX
LINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THREE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OPEN MATTER NOT
LATE BECAUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BEACH SAND HILL
PROPERTY'S PMG PARTNERS WITH
THE COALITION COUNCIL INFILL
BUILDERS AND GREENBELT ALLIANCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN THREE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KIMBERLY DONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THE BILLS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT THREE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THREE SIX SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOUR SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS KIRTI
FOLLOWING CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE BURY COUNCIL AND AS A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT FOR SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR THIS IS BOB
NEAL REPRESENTING FIELD SAID IN
COMPANY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE FOR SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SURE MEMBERS OUT FOR
A GOOD STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION TRANSPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FOR AB-
DIFFERENT. LEVELS. SEVENTY
FOUR. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE THREE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MEAN BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
WRITER THREE THREE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT THREE
FIVE SEVEN. YES THIS IS MY THE
COLOSSAL RODRIGUEZ FROM
SOCIALLY COULD YOU CATION AND
I'M CALLING IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF ANY WITNESSES IN
THE AUDIENCE. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE. CNN I HAVE A MOTION
BY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY I
BELIEVE IS SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. RIVAS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRING IN
THE BILL FORD AND FOR YOUR
STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO THIS
ISSUE. IS IMPORTANT MAKE SURE
OUR LAWS ON THE BOOKS CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED AS INTENDED AND I
BELIEVE YOUR BILL IS DESIGNED
TO DO JUST THAT I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY. MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY NIGHT. IRAQI
LACKEY I BLOOM. BLOOM I BURGER.
RAMOS HI RAMOS I THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS. ROBERT RIVERSIDE
VOEPEL HI VOEPEL HI SIX ZERO.
THE BILL'S NOT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANKS FOR
THE GOOD WORK ON THAT OKAY
LET'S MOVE ON I'M GOING BACK
INTO LAW LET'S SEE. NEXT WILL
BE I DON'T SEE MISTER. MISTER
GALLAGHER ITEM NUMBER FIVE
EIGHT THIRTY SIX FOLLOWED BY
YOUR OTHER ONE AS WELL MR
GALLAGHER. BUT THAT WAS A
CONSERVATORY THANK YOU. THE
BILL. RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- AND I WANT
TO START BY THINKING THAT.
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS BILL- HAD THIS
BILL LAST YEAR AND YOU MADE THE
COMMITMENT THEN TO HELP ME.
WORK THROUGH THIS AND- I THINK
WE FOUND A GOOD PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT WE CAN MOVE
FOR THIS CAN BE VERY HELPFUL-
AB THIRTY SIX. WOULD HELP THE
TOWN OF PARADISE. RECOVER FROM
THE DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF THE
CAMPFIRE. AND I WANT TO REPORT
TO YOU TO THE COMMITTEE MANY OF
YOU- SEVERAL YOU CAME UP TO
PARADISE- IN THE IMMEDIATE
AFTERMATH THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
GREAT PROGRESS- JUST GOT NOTICE
YESTERDAY THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTIETH. HOME WAS REBUILT- IN
PARADISE- YESTERDAY- AND SO.
THEY'RE MAKING GOOD PROGRESS
THERE'S STILL A LONG WAY TO GO
OF COURSE AND- AND ONE OF THE
BIG ISSUES THERE IS IT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND- AND AS WE
REBUILD SAFER. AND MORE
RESILIENT- IN THE TOWN- SEWER
IS GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT-
ONE OF THINGS THEY'RE LOOKING
AS IF THEY CAN HAVE THAT SEWER
IN THE- IN THE DOWNTOWN.
CORRIDOR STYLE ACTUALLY HELP-
ALLOW FOR MORE DENSE.
DEVELOPMENT ALONG THE
EVACUATION. FOUR DOORS WHICH
ARE BEING IMPROVED- AND IN
ADDITION TO HELPING THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY- OF
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENT THERE IN
THE IN THE CORE- SO AB THIRTY
SIX WOULD ALLOW FOR. YOUR
DESIGN BUILD- PROCUREMENT. FOR
THE SEWER AND WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE A SEWER WATER
PIPELINE- AND IT'S ALSO PART OF
A REGIONAL PLAN THAT IS BEING
LOOKED INTO RIGHT NOW- TO
CONNECT THE SEWER TO A REGIONAL
PLAN IN CHICO- AND ALSO TO HAVE
A WATER PIPELINE THAT CAN BE
USED. TO HELP CERTAINLY
PARADISE BUT ALSO THE REGION IN
TERMS OF MEETING ITS WATER
GOALS AND WATER STEWARDSHIP-
MEETING GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS- SO WHAT
IT DOES IS IT PROVIDES THAT
DESIGN BUILD PROCUREMENT A
LITTLE UPDATE ON WHERE THEY ARE
WITH THIS RIGHT NOW THE TOWN.
HAS DECIDED TO PROCEED WITH THE
REGIONAL OPTION CONNECTING WITH
THE CITY OF CHICO'S WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANT. PROJECT IS
CURRENTLY IN PHASE TWO WHICH
INCLUDES ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
AS SO THAT WILL BE GOING TO
THERE'S GOING TO BE PUBLIC.
COMMENT PUBLIC REVIEWS PUBLIC
MEETINGS. AND THEN PHASE THREE
OF THE PROJECT WHICH INCLUDES
THE DESIGN PROCUREMENT IS
PLANNED AND PROJECTED FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SO THE WATER
PIPELINE IS ANOTHER CRITICAL
PROJECT SEPARATE FROM THE
SEWER. THAT WOULD BENEFIT FROM
DESIGN BUILD AUTHORITY THAT'S
WHAT WE HAVE BOTH IN HERE. THE
PARADISE YOU'RE A GEISHA
DISTRICT WHICH IS THE WATER
DISTRICT- PROVIDES DRINKING
WATER SERVICE TO THE TOWN AND
IT LOST MOST OF ITS RATEPAYER
BASE. I DO THE CAMPFIRE MANY OF
YOUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT YOU
REALIZE THAT'S HE SAW THE SAME
COST OF OPERATING THE SYSTEM-
BUT OBVIOUSLY NOT THE SAME
REVENUE- WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE
PROVIDED TWO YEARS WORTH OF
BACK FILL TO THE DISTRICT TO
HELP THEM GET THROUGH. THE LONG
TERM THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO
BE ABLE TO TRANSFER WATER.
REGIONALLY WITHIN BUTTE COUNTY.
TO HELP SUPPORT- CHICO- IN THE
SURROUNDING AREAS- AND YOU
COUNTY BUT ALSO THEN ALSO
SUPPORT A REVENUE STREAM FOR
THE TOWN AS A AS THEIR
REBUILDING THEY WILL KEEP GET
BACK TO. YOU ALL RIGHT
RATEPAYER BASE- AND BE ABLE TO
SUSTAIN THEMSELVES ECONOMICALLY-
SO THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
BILL BE VERY HELPFUL. AS THEY
ARE MOVING FOR THIS TO BE A
GREAT TOOL AND HELP THEM TO
BUILD THESE PROJECTS- IN A
TIMELY FASHION- AND- IN A MORE
COST EFFECTIVE WAY AS WE KNOW
THE DESIGN BUILD. BUT ALSO AS
WE DO WITH MANY OF THESE BILLS
PROVIDE FOR SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE- INITIALLY WE HAVE
LOCAL PEOPLE. WORKING ON THIS
ON THIS PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT.
AND THAT PEOPLE ARE AND SKILLED
AND PEOPLE ARE GETTING TRAINED-
IN ADDITION GETTING THAT YOU
KNOW A LOT OF US TALK ABOUT
THAT C. T. AND WANTING TO HAVE.
RAIN PEOPLE TO LEARN A TRADING
AND GET INTO THE TRADES FOR
THAT SUSTAINABLE- LIFE. GOING
FORWARD SO. MANY GOOD THINGS
THAT THIS THIS BILL PROVIDES-
REALLY WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT AND HERE TO TESTIFY. IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL IS KEVIN
PHILLIPS- FROM. THE TOWN
MANAGER PARADISE. AND ANDREW
MEREDITH ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'LL FIGHT WILL TAKE THE FIRST-
SUPPORT WITNESSED FROM THE
GALLERY HERE LIKE TO SPEAK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRPERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
HALF MILLION MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
ARE PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL. AS YOU'RE ALL AWARE
THE CAMPFIRE HAD A DEVASTATING
IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITY IN
PARADISE AND BUTTE COUNTY AS A
WHOLE. WELL OUR MEMBERS ARE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN REBUILDING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN PARADISE
REBUILDING THE COMMUNITY ITSELF
HAS PROVEN TO BE MORE
DIFFICULT. THE CAMPFIRE LEFT
BEHIND THE COMMUNITY IN DIRE
NEED OF OPTIONS FOR SEWER
TREATMENT AND ABUNDANCE OF
COMMITTED WATER RESOURCES
WITHOUT A CUSTOMER BASE. TO
DELIVER IT TO. AS MENTIONED
BEFORE THE CAMPFIRE PARADISE
WAS THE LARGEST INCORPORATED
CITY IN CALIFORNIA WITHOUT A
SEWER TREATMENT SYSTEM. NEW
STANDARDS FOR SEPTIC SYSTEMS
HAVE MADE MANY RESIDENTIAL LOTS
AND BUILDABLE AT THE MOMENT.
THIS IS DRAMATICALLY SLOWED THE
REBUILDING OF PARADISE. WITHOUT
A MUNICIPAL SEWER OPTION IT
COULD TAKE DECADES TO FULLY
REBUILD THE COMMUNITY. EVEN
WORSE WITHOUT OPTIONS THAT
ALLOW FOR THE PARADISE
REGULATION DISTRICT TO REMAIN
SOLVENT. WE COULD SUDDENLY LOSE
THEM AS WELL. P. IDEA PLEASE
MEMBERS OF TEAMSTERS LOCAL ONE
THIRTY SEVEN MANY OF WHOM LOST
HOMES IN THE CAMPFIRE. IF WE
LOSE P. ID MANY GOOD PAYING
MIDDLE CLASS UNION JOBS WILL BE
LOST. WE FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT AB
THIRTY SIX PROVIDES OPTIONS FOR
BOTH THE TOWN OF PARADISE. IN
P. ID THAT WILL HELP TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF THE
CAMPFIRE. IF STUDIES SHOW A
PIPELINE FROM PARADISE IS
FEASIBLE TO CONNECT BOTH PLDT
WILLING BUYER AND THE TOWN OF
PARADISE TO REGIONAL SEWER
PLANT. AB THIRTY SIX LET THEM
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING. DESIGN
BUILD MODELS WILL ENSURE.
ENABLE A CONTRACTOR TO BE
SELECTED IN BEGIN IMPORTANT
WORK WELL BEFORE SHOVEL HITS
THE DIRT. YOU'LL ALSO TYPES
GOLDENTREE PROVISIONS. TO THE
PROPOSED PROJECT WE BELIEVE AB
THIRTY SIX IS IMPORTANT WE
BELIEVE IT IS NECESSARY AND WE
BELIEVE IT. BUT THE TIMING IS
IMPORTANT. WE ARE DRIVERS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR MEREDITH NOW
WILL HAVE KEVIN PHILLIPS FROM
THE TOWN OF PARADISE I BELIEVE
HE'S ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU AND TO ASK YOU TO
CONTINUE THE SUPPORT FOR THE
TOWN OF PARADISE AND IS
RECOVERING AFTER- IN ORDER TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR RETAIL.
WE NEED TO UPDATE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PARTICULAR
SEWER COLLECTION SYSTEM AND
TREATMENT SYSTEM IS CRITICAL TO
ATTRACTING BUSINESSES BACK. AND
SUPPORTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD
AGGRESSIVELY ON IMPLEMENTING
THE PARIS OR PROJECT IN ITS
MOST ECONOMICAL AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY MANNER
POSSIBLE CURRENTLY WE ARE
PREPARING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS NEEDED TO OBTAIN
CLEARANCES AND PERMITS. FOR THE
PROJECT DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION. THE GEISHA
DISTRICT IS ALSO IN THE PROCESS
OF WORKING THROUGH AN OPTION
STUDY LOOKING AT OPTIONS TO
STAY FISCALLY SOLVENT. ONE OF
THESE OPTIONS INCLUDE DINNER
TYPE PRODUCT PIPELINE WITH THE
CITY OF CHICO TO DELIVER
POSSIBLE WATER TO THE CITY.
THIS WOULD HELP WITH GROUND
WATER ISSUES IN THE VALLEY AND
KEEP THE IRRIGATION DISTRICTS
OFTEN THROUGH THE REBUILD
PROCESS. AB THIRTY SIX WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE USE OF DESIGN
BUILD DELIVERY METHOD FOR THE
PARADISE OR AND THE PHP
INTERPROCESS JECT. DESIGN BUILD
AT THE PROCUREMENT METHOD THAT
BOTH THE DESIGNER AND BUILDER
WORKING TOGETHER. EARLY IN THE
PROCESS AND ALLOWS THE
INNOVATION IMPROVEMENT DESIGN
FEATURES THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
WHICH CAN PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS IN COMPARISON THE
DESIGN BUILD NOT THAT. THE
DESIGN BID BUILD METHODS WHILE
EFFECTIVE DOES DOES NOT BRING
THE THINKERS AND DOERS TOGETHER
IN THE SAME MANNER. TO WORK OUT
WORK OUT ISSUES IN COMPLEX THAT
DESIGN BUILD IS A METHOD THAT
CAN PROVE TIME SAVINGS AS WELL
AS COST SAVINGS WHICH ARE TWO
THINGS THE TOWN NEEDS. TO GET A
RECOVERY MOVING QUICKLY
RECOGNIZING THAT THE-
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATOR HAD
PREVIOUSLY ENACTED THIS
LEGISLATION AUTHORIZING THE USE
A BILL. DESIGNED ALL BURKE
ABOUT THEIR COMMUNITIES WE URGE
THIS CAN GET COMMITTEE TOO FAR.
AND I VOTE ON THE ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTY SIX YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- PHILIP REAL NOW MOVE ON-
WITH AND SO YOUR NAME YOU'RE-
AND YOUR POSITION. OPERATOR
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT SIX IN Q. WILL GO TWICE
FOUR FOUR EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MATT BROWN
ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS
IMPAIRED AT YOUR GEISHA
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE FOR
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT IN TURN MEMBERS CHRIS
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
RIGHT FOR SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTY ABOUT MOM BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
BOILERMAKERS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU RIGHT FOR SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DILLON GIBBONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU RIGHT FOR TWELVE PLEASE.
WELL. THE TRADE SUPPORT. NOT
TAKE. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT I'D LIKE TO
TAKE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE
IN THE GALLERY. HELLO DEVON
EVERS PLASTERS AND CEMENT
MASONS LOCAL THREE HUNDRED AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF
THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES AND
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES ALSO
LENT SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I BELIEVE WE HAVE ALL
THOSE THAT ARE IN SUPPORT. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT FIFTY.
SUZMAN THIRTY SIX I'VE DONE
THAT TWICE. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. RIGHT
FOR SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EXCUSE ME WE HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION
BY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER LUCKY A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VEPEL I WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN. YOU'RE VERY
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS TO HELP
THE PARADISE COMMUNITY A
COMMUNITY RECOVER REBUILD AFTER
ONE OF THE GREATEST TRAGEDIES
IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY. WATER
AND SEWER SERVICES ARE NOT
LUXURIES THEY ARE ESSENTIAL TO
OUR HEALTH AND SAFETY. OF ALL
THESE PRODUCTS ARE BEING
EVALUATED I SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TO ALLOW THE USE OF DESIGN BILL
TO EXPEDIA AT THE CONSTRUCTION
WAS HAVE SECURED THE NECESSARY
APPROVALS. AND AS YOU MIGHT
KNOW SOME OF YOUR- CONSTITUENTS
CALLED AND THEY WERE CONCERNED
AND I WOULD ASSURE THEM THAT
YOU WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM. SO I JUST WANTED TO I
KNOW YOU ARE SO JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE WAS ON THE RECORD SO
THE MOMENT MOTION TODAY IS DUE
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY HI
THERE CURRY ADDED LACKEY LACKEY
I BLOOM WILL AYE
BOERNER HORVATH. RAMOS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS VOEPEL
HI VOEPEL. NUMBER FOUR ZERO.
PARDON OKAY BILLS ON CALL. OKAY
I THINK DID YOU ME TO PRESS ON
IF YOU KNOW YEAR ON CONSENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEASURE
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME ALL RIGHT
LET'S SEE AND WHO IS HERE I
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THIS
AREA. WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO NEXT.
OKAY WE'RE MOVING TO ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THIS
AREA. SEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES- PROBABLY REPRESENT
PUBLIC PROBABLY PRESENTING AB
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT I AM
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THANK YOUFOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND
MYSELF- TO REVISE THE SENSE
THAT THE TO DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY I
BELIEVE SHOULD BE THIRTY SIX I
HAVE MY WRONG NOTES TWENTY
THIRTY SIX- THIS BILL ALLOWS
THE STATE'S PUBLICLY OWNED
ELECTRIC- UTILITIES TO UTILIZE
RATE REDUCTION BONDS. JUST AS
LOCAL PUBLIC WATER AND
WASTEWATER UTILITIES AND AYE
YOU USE ARE ALLOWED UNDER
CURRENT LAW MAINTAINING
AFFORDABLE ELECTRIC RATES IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND EIGHTY SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT WILL PROVIDE A
USEFUL TOOL TO HELP KEEP
BORROWING COSTS LOW AND KEEP
ELECTRIC RATES AFFORDABLE RATE
REDUCTION BONDS TYPICALLY OFFER
LOWER INTEREST RATES THAN
TRADITIONAL REVENUE BONDS AND
ARE THERE FOR A FINANCING TOOL.
THAT PEELED USE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO UTILIZE TO SAVE ON PROJECT
AND PROGRAM COSTS THIS CHEAPER
FINANCING TOOL IS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE TO LOCAL PUBLIC WATER
AND WASTEWATER UTILITIES. AND
TO I WILL USE BUT IT IS NOT
AVAILABLE TO PO USE AND THEIR
CUSTOMERS THERE'S NO PUBLIC
POLICY RATIONALE FOR THIS
IMBALANCE IN LAW IN CLOSING
THIS BILL WILL REDUCE BORROWING
COSTS FOR PO USE AND THEIR
CUSTOMERS WHEN MAKING
INVESTMENTS TO MEET THE STATE'S
CLIMATE GOALS MITIGATE
WILDFIRES. ENHANCE SAFETY AS
WELL AS ADDRESS DEBT THAT HAS
ACCUMULATED DUE TO SOME
CUSTOMERS AND ABILITY TO PAY
THEIR ELECTRIC BILLS DURING THE
CONTINUING COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY. WITH ME IS PATRICK
WELCH AND PAUL HAUSER. I
BELIEVE THEY SHOULD BE ON THE
CALL YEAH I BY HAVE TO PATRICK
WELCH FROM ON THE PHONE I
BELIEVE. THE BILL. AFTER
QUALITY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE POLICE STATION I THANK
THE CHAIR AND AUTHOR OF THE
WORK ON THE ISSUE. CALIFORNIA
SIX MEDIA LOCK ALECTRA. BY RELY
PORTABLE ELECTRICITY ABOUT 25%
THEY- YEAH I HAVE A CUSTOMER TO
THE ISSUANCE OF REVENUE BOND
ISSUES MAKING THAT. OUR SUPPORT
STATE AND LOCAL. WILDCARD
EDUCATION FIFTY AND MUCH MORE.
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
OPERATORS RATE REDUCTION BONDS
WHICH TYPICALLY GARNER LOWER
INTEREST RATE BERMAN BONTA
EIGHTY. MONEY BREAK WITHOUT HIM
ON THE SUBJECT IF FORCED TO
DECLARE OF PUBLIC LIFE
INCLUDING LOCAL LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL THANK YOU IN ALLEN
PARK LODGES BAKER AND IT COMES
BACK WITH YOU. AND FURTHER
REDUCTION BOND ONLY BE ISSUED
LOWER RATES THAN TRADITIONAL
OFFICE INCLUDING BEFORE THE
ISN'T THAT SERVICE EIGHT SEVEN
EIGHT I WANT TO- OF THE STATE
PUBLICLY UNDER. IS TO MAKE
NEEDED AND REQUIRED INVESTING
CHEAPER COSTS CUSTOMERS. THANK
YOU AND EMAIL RESPECT URGES
YOUR IPHONE ON THE BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER WILL LOOKING FOR
PAUL HAUSER FROM THE TRAY
PUBLIC UTILITIES. DISTRICT ON
THE PHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARED MEMBER MONEY PAUL WHO-
AND I'M THE CHEN MANAGER FOR
TWO PUBLIC UTILITY. ON BEHALF
OF TRYING TO DO YOU DO I WOULD
LIKE EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI
FIFTY EIGHT. THIRTY P. U. D.
PROVIDE THE HUNDRED PER. CAR
FRIEL. TO A- TWO THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN RURAL
TRINITY COUNTY. OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY COVERS TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SQUARE MILES ON IT SOME
OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST FIRE PRONE
AREA. POPULATION WE SERVE IS
ALSO AMONG THE POOREST IN
CALIFORNIA. AS A RESULT OF
CALIFORNIA'S STRICT LIABILITY
STANDARD AS IT RELATES THE
UTILITY WILDFIRE LIABILITY.
TWENTY PD IS NO LONGER ABLE TO
CURE WILDFIRE LIABILITY
INSURANCE. NOT ONLY THIS
BUSINESS EXPOSE THE UTILITY
CONSIDERABLE BANKRUPTCY REAL
BUT ALSO HAS RESULTED IN A
SIGNIFICANT DOWNGRADE YOUR
CREDIT RATING. WE LAST
REFINANCE THAT ON NOVEMBER
FIRST TWENTY SEVENTEEN ON OUR
CREDIT RATING WAS DOUBLE A
MINUS. TODAY OUR CREDIT RATING
IT'S TRIPLE BE PLUS. THIS IS
INCREASE OUR COST OF ACQUIRING
CAPITAL JUST WHEN WE REALLY
NEED TO MAKE INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS TO EXPAND A RIGHT
WAY AND FIVE ARDEN OUR SYSTEM.
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE NEPA
PROCESS. THE WIDE MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED MILES A POWER LINE
RIGHT OF WAY. WHAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PERMITTING IT
COMPLETELY WE WILL TAKE THE
VERY LARGE EXPANSE OF TREATING
THE AREA TO REDUCE FIRE RISK.
ANYTHING YOU DO NEED TO EXPAND
CONSIDERABLE CAPITAL FOR POWER
LINE UPGRADE AND WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT ACQUIRING OTHER
POWERLINE HALF THIS WITHIN THE
COUNTY. AB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
HOLD THE POTENTIAL TO REDUCE
OUR ABOUT BORROWING COSTS THE
WHAT THEY WERE PRIOR TO OUR
CREDIT RATING DOWNGRADE. SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS TO
REDUCE FIRE RISK AND MAKE
ELECTRIC SERVICE MORE RELIABLE
TO OUR RURAL RESIDENTS. WHAT
TWENTY COUNTY BEING ON THE
POOREST COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA'S DIFFICULT TO MAKE
LARGE CAPITAL EXPENDITURES
WITHOUT FINANCING THE EXPENSES
IN SPREADING THE COST OVER
TIME. I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AB SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT. SO THE TRINITY U.
D. AND OTHER PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES CAN ACCESS LOWER.
COST FINANCING THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING OUR POSITION AND I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK MR HOUSER WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. SIMPLY YOUR NAME
YOUR POSITION AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION. Q. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ABC SEVEN
FIVE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FOUR IN Q.
WILL WATCH LINE FOR EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
ROCK ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BURBANK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FOR
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS DILLON
GIBBONS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIDE FOR SEX I'M SORRY FOR
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY REYNOLDS FROM CALIFORNIA
ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT OR SLIDE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU RIGHT FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS GREG COOK REPRESENTING
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA POWER
AGENCY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARIO DIBERNARDO ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BY FOUR THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OTHER DOLLAR WITH THE
CITY OF PALO ALTO UTILITIES
DEPARTMENT ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I SEE
NONE IN THE- GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN FIVE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE ANY QUICK QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE
WE HAVE A MOTION I BELIEVE FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LUCKY. AND THE
SECOND I NEED A SECOND FOR THE
BILL. THE SECOND FROM SOMEONE
WILL TELL. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THIS IS A GREAT
FINANCING TOOL HER FOR WHAT FOR
A IT'S BEEN A GREAT FINANCING
TOOL FOR WATER AGENCIES LOOK
FORWARD TO EXTENDING IT TO- TO
APPEAL TO USE AS WELL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRING IN THE BILL
FORD TEN EIGHT TEN ABLE OUR
PUBLIC ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ANOTHER
FINANCING TOOL FOR NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO CLARIFY THE BILL'S
INTENT AND ENSURE CONTINUED
OVERSIGHT OF THIS YET TO BE
USED TOOL BUT THE AMENDMENT SO
WE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY
AND THE MOTION IS TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY HI LACKEY. LACKEY
I BLOOM BLOOM FIVE
BOERNER HORVATH. RAMOS HI
THREE OF US HI ROB RIVAS.
VOEPEL I WILL TELL. YOU KNOW IT
FALLS FIVE FIVE ZERO YOUR BILLS
ON CALL THANK YOU TO HAVE IT ON
THAT OKAY YOU'RE OUT THANK YOU
FREE. I WILL GO BACK IN THE
ORDER HERE LET'S SEE WHAT WE
HAVE HERE HAHA ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN- ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA.
AB. ELEVEN NINETY FIVE. WELCOME
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON- THAT
ENSURE A MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR OF AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR. THEIR WORK ON
THIS AND I FEEL THE- WORKING AT
THE VERY STAKEHOLDERS I HAVE
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED TO ME INCLUDING ONE.
I BEGAN TO WORK WITH THE STATE
WATER BOARD ON HOW THEY CAN
IMPLEMENT A REGIONAL SOLUTION
TO ADDRESSING SAFE DRINKING
WATER IN SOUTHERN L. A. COUNTY.
TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
REGIONAL AND LOCAL CLAPPER
CONSOLIDATION OF FAILING SMALL
WATER AGENCIES WHERE THAT MAKES
THE MOST SENSE FOR SUSTAINABLE
DRINKING WATER SYSTEM IN OUR
REGION. L. LASKO HAS SOME IDEAS.
FOR HOW OUR ALLEY LASKO MAY BE
ABLE TO PLAY AN ACTIVE ROLE IN
CONSULTING CONSOLIDATIONS. AND
WE ARE WORKING WITH THEM. AS
WELL COLLABORATION WITH
REGIONAL WATER LEADERS NUMBER
THREE OR COLLABORATING WITH
REGIONAL WATER HEATERS. TEN IF
I IDENTIFY MEMBERS OF THE
TECHNICAL ADVISORY BOARD.
YOU'LL BE HEARING FROM OF THAT
OR IF THEY GOT BODIES THEY DS.
AB LATE ELEVEN NINETY FIVE
WOULD BRING STATE WATER BOARD
ATTENTION TO ONE OF THE STATE'S
REGIONAL HOT SPOTS WITH SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS. THAT ARE
PROBLEMS PROVIDING THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS SAFE DRINKING
WATER. RAISE THE BAR TO CREATE
A POSITION TITLE COMMISSIONER.
FOR THE SOUTHERN L. A. COUNTY
REGION THE COMMISSIONER WILL
LEAD REGIONAL COLLABORATIONS TO
DEVELOP A PLAN. FOR SUSTAINABLE
DRINKING WATER WHICH MAY
INCLUDE CONSOLIDATION OF SOME
SMALL AGENCIES. THE
COMMISSIONER ALSO WILL PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
FUNDING AND LEAD EFFORTS TO FIX
PROBLEMS AND OF WITH
CONTAMINATED GROUNDWATER.
FINALLY THE COMMISSIONER WILL
EXERCISE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
CENTRAL BASIN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN ORDER TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY IN OPERATIONS OR
PASSED EIGHT AUDITS HAVE
REVEALED PROBLEMS. SINCE THE
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WATER
BOND THAT WE HAVE FOCUSED OUR
ATTENTION ON FIXING WATER
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE DIFFICULTY
PROVIDING SAFE DRINKING WATER
TO CALIFORNIANS. THE STATE
WATER BOARDS RECENT STATEWIDE
NEEDS ASSESSMENTS ON SAFE
DRINKING WATER IDENTIFIED L. A.
COUNTY AS AMONG THE TOP BY
COUNTY THIS MALL WATER SYSTEMS
AT RISK OF FAILURE. EVERYTHING
YOU SEE OTHER REPORT
HIGHLIGHTED THE FACT THAT THE
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS THAT ARE
FEELING ON THE VERGE OF FAILING
ARE CONCENTRATED IN SOUTHERN L.
A. COUNTY. AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE CONNECTS RESOURCES FROM
THE WATER BOARD DIRECTLY TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS. THE BILL
AUTHORIZES THE FORMATION OF A
TECHNICAL ADVISORY BOARD AND
THE BOARD WILL INCLUDE WATER
EXPERTS ON THE REGION QUALIFY
TO DEVELOP AND OFFER SOLUTIONS
TO WATER. COMMISSIONERS. FOR
THE SECOND TIME I WILL I WILL-
LEAVE THE REST OF MY COMMENTS
I'M SURE THEY WILL BE PART OF
THE QUESTIONS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- WILL MOVE ON
TO YOUR SUPPORT AND I BELIEVE
THE CITIZENS. MISTER ORTEGA.
FOR THE CALPERS HOSTED MUTUAL
YEAH COMMITTEE AT AFTERNOON
WELCOME. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRPERSON OF OUR CURRY VICE
CHAIR LACKEY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME THAT I DON'T
THINK I'M TESTIFYING IN MY
CAPACITY AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES
RECOGNIZING THAT AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE IS A WORK OF
PROGRESS I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA PROVIDING
NEEDED TESTIFYING FOR HER
STEADY FOCUS ON SMALL WATER
SYSTEM ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA AND
SOUTHEAST L. A. IN PARTICULAR.
WE HAVE FAITH IN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA'S WORK ON EIGHT ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE THAT IS BRINGING
STAKEHOLDERS IN SOUTHEAST DELHI
TOGETHER MUCH IN THE SAME WAY
THAT SENATOR DODD BROUGHT
STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND CENTRAL COAST
TOGETHER PASSED IN SB TWO
HUNDRED IN THE SAFER PROGRAM
UNDER THE STATE WATER BOARD.
UNLIKE THE CENTRAL VALLEY URBAN
AREAS OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
NOW HAVE REGIONAL WATER
AGENCIES POSITION TO HELP SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE COULD REMOVE OBSTACLES AND
DELAYS THESE REGIONAL AGENCIES
FACE AND HELP BETTER LEVERAGE
STATE DOLLARS. AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
CONSORTIUM COULD BE A
SUCCESSFUL FOLLOW UP TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE GIPSON AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THAT HELP
TO DISSOLVE THE CITY BUT COUNTY
WATER DISTRICT AND HELP LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AS ADMINISTRATOR
TO FORMULATE LONG TERM A LONG
TERM PLAN TO HELP TO KEEP THIS
RESIDENTS ATTAIN GOOD WATER
QUALITY AND SERVICE AT A
REASONABLE COST. WE ARE
RECOMMENDED TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA THAT THE HUMAN RIGHT TO
WATER COLLABORATIVE'S ADVISORY
COMMITTEE LEVERAGE WHAT WE
LEARNED FROM THE CITY OF
EXPERIENCE AND INCLUDE
TECHNICAL PROFESSIONALS FROM
THE ENTITIES THAT ENCOMPASS THE
SCOPE OF AUTHORITY AND
RESOURCES NEEDED IN CASES LIKE
TO TEVA AS WELL AS IN HELPING
LESS SEVERELY IMPAIRED SYSTEM.
FOR THE SAKE OF TIME ALL I WILL
NOT GO TO THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WE'RE SUGGESTING WE ARE
EAGER TO REVIEW LANGUAGE
PROVIDED BY STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
AREA AS WELL AS THE STATE WATER
BOARD ADDRESSING WATER RIGHT
THE REALITY IS THAT WHILE SOME
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES CHARGE
HIGHER WATER RATES ONE COMPANY
IN PARTICULAR CHARGES THE
LOWEST WATER RATES IN CENTRAL
BASIN. WELL HAVING WATER RIGHTS
AND THE CENTRAL BASIN IS A KEY
COMPONENT OF AFFORDABILITY
IMPORTED WATER RATES. ARE WOULD
DRIVE THE COST OF WATER UP
WORDS TO CONSUME AND SENT BASIN.
WITH REGARDS TO CAN. SPEAKER AB
TWO. A MY GARCIA AB FLIGHTS
INFO ASSEMBLYMEMBERS. OF THE B.
FIFTY FOUR. BACK GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR- TO NOT FOR
PROFIT MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES I
REPRESENT. EITHER OF YOU ARE IN
THE STATE WATER BOARD HAVE ALSO
DEVISED RICHMOND TRICKS OR
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS. THAT'S WE
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO CREATE
METRICS FOR OTHER TYPES OF
WATER AGENCIES SO THAT REMEDIES
FOR ADDRESSING ISSUES ABOUT
DEFICIENCIES IN GOVERNANCE
FINANCE AND ETHICS. DON'T HAVE
TO RESULT IN LEGISLATIVE
INTERVENTION AND REPETITIVE
STATE AUDITS FOR EXAMPLE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OPERATE UNDER SUCH
STANDARDS WOULD DEFINE TRIGGERS
THAT RESULT IN THE ASSIGNMENT
OF STATE ADMINISTRATORS TO
CORRECT DEFICIENCIES WHEN A
DISTRICT FALLS BELOW STANDARDS.
IN MANY WAYS THE TECHNICAL
CAPACITY CREATED FOR SOUTHEAST
LOS ANGELES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND- YOU BE ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE IN THE HUMAN RIGHT
TO WATER COLLABORATIVE. CAN
HELP THE REGION CATCH UP TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN QUALIFYING
NEEDS MADE POSSIBLE THROUGH THE
SAFER PROGRAM. THAT FEW WOULD
DISPUTE HAS MOSTLY FOCUSED ON
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN THE
CENTRAL COAST. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA'S MEETING WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS IN SOUTHEAST L.
AND HIS PLEDGE TO CONSIDER
AMENDMENTS TO CALIBRATE THE
BILL TO PRESIDENT NEEDS. I
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL SHOULD
MOVE FORWARD AND LOOK FORWARD.
TO ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THIRTY ONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NONE OPERATOR. WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT FOR A BI. ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT
FOR A FIRST COMMENT IT LOOKS
LIKE WE HAVE TWO OF THEM THANK
YOU.
FIVE FOUR NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'M PAMELA MILLER
BUT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSION OR CALLOUT CO. WELL
WE CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA AND HER STAFF
HAVE REACHED OUT TO CALLOUT CO
IN LOS ANGELES LASKO FOR
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE REGARDING
INVOLVING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
LASKO IN PARTICULAR. ON THE
DECISION AND IN DOING SO WE'VE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
QUESTIONS CONCERNS AND
SUGGESTIONS. WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
AND HER STAFF AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND LOOK FORWARD
TO ONGOING DIALOGUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M THREE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
BOB ZERO ON BEHALF OF THE WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WELL WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BLL WE'VE HAD VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA AND HER
STAFF AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
ISSUE I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE GALLERY.
SAYING NINE DO WE HAVE ANY ON
ONLINE. OPERATOR. I THINK I'M
LOOKING FOR ALEX ROSS. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ALEX ROSS AND I AM
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE CENTRAL
BASIN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR PROVIDING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE I ALSO WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYWOMAN GARCIA FOR TAKING
AN INTEREST IN GROUND WATER
QUALITY ISSUES IN THE SOUTHEAST
LOS ANGELES COUNTY REGION WE
SHARE THE GOALS OF THE AUTHOR
TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE SAFE
DRINKING WATER TO THE SOUTHEAST
LOS ANGELES COUNTY REGION IN
GENERAL AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN PARTICULAR.
HOWEVER CENTRAL BASIN DOES NOT
SUPPLY OR TREAT GROUNDWATER
THEREFORE IT IS UNCLEAR AS A
WHOLE SO IMPORTED WATER UTILITY
WHY WE ARE INCLUDED IN THIS
BILL. CONSIDERING THAT CENTRAL
BASIN AT IMPLEMENTED ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN AUDIT. AND
OPERATIONALIZE THESE PRACTICES
IN OUR ADMINISTRATIVE CODE. ARE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL CREATES
CONFUSION ABOUT ITS INTENT AND
DETRACTS FROM THE VERY REAL
ISSUES ON GROUND WATER QUALITY
AND THE ONGOING GROUNDWATER
TREATMENT NEEDS OF OUR SERVICE
AREA. SINCE NINETEEN FIFTY TWO
CENTRAL BASIN AS A METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MEMBER AGENCY. HAS
DELIVERED HIGH QUALITY
CONTAMINANT FREE DRINKING WATER
DIRECTLY TO OUR RETAIL WATER
SYSTEMS WITHOUT THE NEED FOR
COSTS FOR ADDITIONAL TREATMENT.
TO ENSURE THE DELIVERY OF SAFE
AND RELIABLE WATER.
METROPOLITAN OPERATES FIVE
WATER TREATMENT PLANT SPOTTED
ON GOING BASIS IT TESTS FOR
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED WATER
CONSTITUENTS IT PERFORMS ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
WATER QUALITY TESTS PER YEAR.
CENTRAL BASIN SERVES TWENTY
FOUR CITIES. WATER DISTRICTS
MITCHELL WATER. INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES A NEARLY TWO MILLION
RESIDENTS. WOULD BE
DISENFRANCHISED BY AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE WHICH WE BELIEVE IS
A STEP BACKWARDS AND LOCAL
GOVERNANCE AND DEMOCRATIC
REPRESENTATION. NOT TO MENTION
THE UNNECESSARY ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS THAT WILL ULTIMATELY BE
PASSED TO THE REPAIRS. AS NOTED
BY THE AUTHOR THERE ARE MANY
WATER CHALLENGES FACING THE
SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES COUNTY
REGION. BUT THE RELIABILITY AND
QUALITY OF OUR DRINKING WATER
IS NOT ONE OF THEM IN ORDER TO
HELP ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES OF
GROUNDWATER QUALITY AND
STABILITY. WE HUMBLY REQUEST AT
THE STATE MORE AGGRESSIVELY
FUND PROJECTS THAT IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF DRINKING WATER. SO
THAT WE CAN CREATE JOBS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR THE BENEFIT OUR
COMMUNITIES. CENTRAL BASIN DOES
NOT BELIEVE OUR INCLUSION IN AB
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE IS
APPROPRIATE. AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE MUST OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I BELIEVE I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO FOR COMFORT
CAPITAL. CAN YOU WITH A%
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION.
NAME ONE GOOD AFTERNOON
CHARACTER AG WE ARE IN MEMBERS
JENNIFER CMPETE ALLOW
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WATER MITIGATION HE
W. A. AS THE STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
DRINKING WATER UTILITY THAT ARE
REGULATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. I
FACED RELIABLE DRINKING WATER
TO ABOUT 15% OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OUR MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN THE
STATE WATER BOARD WORK ON WATER
AND CONSOLIDATION AND WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT
CONSOLIDATION IS AN IMPORTANT
TOOL TO HELP ENSURE EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS FACED AND
RELIABLE DRINKING WATER.
MEMBERS HAVE PARTNERED WITH
THIS ADVANTAGE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE CONSOLIDATION
PROJECT MY CREEK AFFORDABILITY
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY IMPROVE
WATER QUALITY. A. ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE THE NEW
GOVERNMENTAL STRUCTURE.
SILICATE WATER CAN. WITH ABOUT
OF THE WATER ON THE DISTRICT.
THE W. A HOUSE FOR MEMBER
COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE SAFE
RELIABLE DRINKING WATER SERVICE
AREA. WE SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN'S WORK ON THE ISSUE AND
WE BELIEVE THAT A DIFFERENT
SOLUTION IS NEEDED FOR SMALL
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS AND ALL
ANGELES REGION. UNFORTUNATELY
THE BILL INCLUDES A PROVISION
THAT CREATE A PREFERENCE. FOR A
GOVERNMENT RUN WATER SYSTEM
OVER ANY OTHER WATER. YOU TO BE
ABLE THAT THE STATE LOOK COMING.
EVERY OPTION AVAILABLE TO
COMMUNITIES SUFFERING FROM
CONTAMINATED DRINKING WATER HI
RATE FOR BOTH. RATHER THAN
CREATE ANY LIMITATION AB
CURRENTLY DRAFTED IN AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE. I PROPOSED IN THE
BILL OF THE NEW GOVERNMENT
ENTITY WOULD BE STATUTORILY
PROHIBITED FROM CONTEMPLATING A
PARTNERSHIP WITH ONE OF THE W.
EIGHT MEMBERS. EVEN IF THAT
WATER SUPPLIER CAN OFFER
REASONABLE RATES AND IMPROVE
WATER QUALITY CUSTOMER EVAN MY
PANELISTS WITH UNSAFE DRINKING
WATER TO THIRD TO HAVE EVERY
OPTION ON THE TABLE. JOIN
HEARING TODAY WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED A POSITION ON AB
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE. AND OFFER
AN AMENDMENT IN OUR LETTER TO
ALLOW ANY PUBLIC WATERS AND BE
CONSIDERED TO AT THE MALL
FAILING. AND ANGELA. AT THE
MOMENT WILL MAXIMIZE THE
PARTNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
AVAILABLE TO COMMUNITIES
UNLOCKED ANGELES. THAT NEED
ASSISTANCE PROVIDING SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER TO
THEIR RESIDENT. I'LL CLOSE WITH
FINDING FROM THE UCLA STUDY
THAT THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN REFER
TO ENTER OPENING- SAID. I
THIRTY WENT. WITH THE- REGULAR
UTILITY IS WATER SYSTEMS AND
DEFENCEMAN AND SEVERELY.
COMMUNITIES ARE LIKELY TO
REALIZE IMPROVED INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVED WATER QUALITY AND
IMPROVED WATER RELIABILITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
PILLOW- ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OPERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT THREE IN
Q. OR TRYING TO FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO HELLO.
YES. MY NAME IS A WORTHWHILE
AND I ALSO EAGLE EDUCATION I AM
CALLING AS THE REST OF EAST LOS
ANGELES REGION AND I AM
OPPOSING AB. ELEVEN NINETY FIVE
WE NEED A DIFFERENT. NO OPERATE.
THANK YOU RYAN THREE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
HELLO. NINE THREE FIVE SEVEN.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD- THIS IS WHAT THE
CULTURAL VEGANS I AM FROM
SOCIAL EQUAL EDUCATION I'M
CALLING IN OPPOSITION AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE WE NEED TO KEEP A
PRINTER. THANK YOU YOUR LINE
FOR NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
USUALLY A WHOLE WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER ISSUE I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SEEING NONE IN THE
GALLERY. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. FOR
LIKE IT'S IN MOTION. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MOTION
BINDERS RIVAS SECOND BY TASHA
WHO ORDER HARPER I'M GONNA GET
A RIGHT ONE DAY- AUTHOR RICHARD
TO CLOSE. YES I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
OPPOSITION- FOR THE CENTRAL
BASE THEN I WANT TO MAKE IT
THROUGH THE COMMISSION IS THAT
HAVE. ONLY HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
OVERSEE AND NOT OPERATE THE
CENTRAL BASE AND- AND SO WHEN
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS
OFFENSE I THINK VOTERS THAT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME. IN
ADDITION IT'S BEEN A TRAVEL
AGENCY- FOR MANY YEARS- WE'VE
DONE A NUMBER OF THINGS AND SO
IF THEY ARE DOING THOUGH. GOOD
TO WORK THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE DOING THE COMMISSIONER
WILL LET US KNOW THAT AND
HOPEFULLY STATE TO. REGAIN THE
PUBLIC'S TRUST ALONG THE WAY-
OUR PRIVATELY OWNED- INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES- THE BILL STILL
ALLOWS VOLUNTARY CONSOLIDATION.
WHICH IS WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE A PUBLIC OPTION OUT
THERE AS WELL. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I BUILT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HOME PRISON THE
BILL AND I KNOW THAT WATER
PROVISION WITHIN YOUR
COMMUNITIES IS A VERY COMPLEX.
LONGSTANDING ISSUE THE DESERVES
FURTHER DISCUSSION. WELL I
CERTAINLY SHARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION THIS
BILL IS CURRENTLY A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPONENTS. AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND A
COLLABORATIVE SOLUTION TO THE
DRINKING WATER CHALLENGES OF L.
A. COUNTY. I BELIEVE THE
FINDING. INNOVATIVE WAYS TO ME
TO THE DRINKING WATER NEEDS OF
OUR COMMUNITIES IS GOING TO BE
CRUCIAL AS CLIMATE CHANGE
CONTINUES TO PRESENT NEW WATER
SUPPLY AND WATER QUALITY
CHALLENGES STATEWIDE. IS
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS COMMITTEE.
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THANK YOU. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY IRAQI. LOU I WILL
HI BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH ALL RIGHT RAMOS.
THREE OF US HI YOU RIVERSIDE
ROBERT RIVAS RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
WE'LL TELL THEM VOTING. YOU
HAVE FIVE ZERO THAT'S. FIVE
ZERO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
NEXT WILL HAVE A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE AND ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB. THREE THREE NINE. WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THREE NINE A BILL TO EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO ENGAGE WITH THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND FIRST I
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING OF MANY MANY
HOURS WITH US ON THIS BILL
MAKING ITS- WHAT IT IS TODAY I
FIRST I DISCUSSED THE
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS THAT
I'VE ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE'S
REQUEST THAT. VASTLY PARKS THIS
BILL DOWN- SO WE'LL GO THROUGH
THAT SPEAKS A LOT ABOUT THE
SUBSTANCE IT LIMITS THE BILL'S
APPLE GIVE WILL APPLICABILITY
TO THE MEETINGS OF CITY
COUNCILS AND COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ONLY AND ONLY IN
THE JURISDICTIONS WHICH CONTAIN
A POPULATION OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE OR MORE A
QUARTER MILLION PEOPLE. OR
INTERNET NOT AND GIVING LOCAL
AGENCIES FLEXIBILITY IN
IMPLEMENTATION WE ALSO REMOVED
LANGUAGE REQUIRED TO A
OPERABILITY OF THE FOR INTERNET
REDUCING COST REMOVED ALL
LANGUAGE REQUIREMENTS ENGLISH
TRANSLATION AND INTERPRETATION
PROVISIONS REMOVED LANGUAGE
ALLOWING LOCAL AGENCIES TO
REQUIRE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO REGISTER IN ORDER TO RIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE HAVE
ADDED A SUNSET DATE FOR
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. PREJUDICE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WE HAD
PREVIOUSLY MADE SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENTS TO CUT DOWN COSTS
BASED ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FEEDBACK SUGGESTS SCALING BACK
LANGUAGE TRANSLATION
REQUIREMENTS AND REMOVING
REQUIREMENTS FOR CLOSED
CAPTIONING. BUT MEMBERS THIS
BILL IS LONG OVERDUE FOR TOO
LONG MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HAVE
BEEN PRECLUDED FROM
PARTICIPATING IN GOVERNMENT DUE
TO REQUIREMENTS TO ATTEND IN
PERSON. THERE ARE A MYRIAD OF
REASONS WHY SOMEONE WOULD BE
UNABLE TO ATTEND SAY A TUESDAY
NIGHT SEVEN PM CITY COUNCIL
MEETING AND SIT THERE FOR
SEVERAL HOURS OR TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT JUST SO THEIR
VOICES HEARD. YOU KNOW THEY
COULD BE WORKING THEY MIGHT
HAVE CHILDREN TAKE CARE OF.
ETCETERA THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE IN CITY COUNCIL OR
COUNTY BOARD OF COUNTY BOARDS
OF SUPERVISORS MEETING EITHER
IN PERSON TELEPHONICALLY OR
THROUGH THE INTERNET. THIS BILL
IS ESPECIALLY TIMELY GIVEN THAT
LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE ALREADY HAD
TO IMPLEMENT WAYS FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO ENGAGE
REMOTELY WE WANT TO SEE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES CONTINUE AFTER
THE PANDEMIC. IN ORDER FOR US
TO HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO HEAR THE VOICES OF ALL OUR
CONSTITUENTS SIR RESPECTFLLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
THREE THREE NINE AND WITH THAT
I HAVE TWO SPEAKERS THAT
SUPPORT TODAY. A LIVE YES THEY
DEMAND FROM LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
AND BONNIE LIEBERMAN SANTA
CLARA UNIFIED SCHOOL BOARD
TRUSTEE IN MY DISTRICT. THANK
YOU ROOM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OPERATOR WE'RE FOR A LIVING
DETERMINE FOR BY. LEVER THANK
YOU BOTH SIDES ARE OPEN. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MANY MIDDLE OF THE
ASSIGNMENT I CAN GAUGE WHAT
COORDINATOR WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WE ARE CO
SPONSORED EIGHTY THREE THIRTY
NINE THE IDEA FOR WHICH CAME
FROM OUR ON THE GROUND
EXPERIENCE ADVOCATING FOR
EQUITABLE POLICIES EQUAL ACCESS
TO OPPORTUNITY OLYMPIC BROKE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS AGAIN
WATCHING IT. DURING COACHELLA
VALLEY. PAGE ENDEAVORED
DECISION NOT OF. IT IS THE
RIGHT AND IT DOESN'T. UPON
ELECTED A- PROVIDE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE WITH THE- TO PARTNER.
NOT JUST THOSE FOR WHOM
PARTICIPATION IF NEED BE. IN
THE PAST IS THE THING THAT'S
WHAT HE BECOME MORE VISIBLE TO
THOSE WHO HAVE ALWAYS HAD THE
PRIVILEGE TO IGNORE THEM.
BECOME CLEAR THAT GOVERNMENT
ALONE CANNOT SOLVE THE MOST
PRESSING RACIAL SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE ISSUES OF OUR
TIME. WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MEANINGFULLY EXPAND ACCESS TO
THE PUBLIC MITIGATING SOME OF
THE INVESTORS AND THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION PROCESS THAT YOU
SEE TODAY. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A MORE JUST
AND EQUITABLE STATE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE ALL
VOICES ARE HEARD IN DECISION
MAKING ESPECIALLY ALREADY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES. WORLD
WORKING CLASS FOLKS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. SENIORS AND
PEOPLE OF THE BILL LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH. WE ENVISION
A CALIFORNIA WERE ALL PUBLIC
MEETINGS INTERACT WITH REMOTE
PARTICIPATION IN LANGUAGE
SERVICES IMPORTANT
MODERNIZATION TO CREATE A
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY PUBLIC
PROP BACK. OVER A HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE FROM DIVERSE LOCATIONS IN
THE DIVERSE CONSTITUENCIES. THE
COURT DECISION A CALIFORNIA
CITY HOW IT WOULD POSITIVELY
IMPACT COMMUNITY TO
HISTORICALLY BEEN MARGINALIZED
THE GOVERNMENT'S DECISION
MAKING PROCESS. WORLD COMMUNITY
PEOPLE CAN WORKING CAN'T TAKE
TIME TO ATTEND PUBLIC MEETINGS
IN PERSON. DISABILITY INTO YOUR
RECORDS AND PEOPLE WHO SPEAK A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH
OFTEN SERVICE YOU GET THE TABLE
AND HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PUBLIC DECISIONS THAT AFFECT
THEM. THIS WOULD BE. A LITTLE
CALIFORNIA. WE WORK WITH MY- TO
LOOK FINAL RESPECT ON THE OF
FOR FIVE MINUTE. TO THE COUNTY
BOARD OF. EMERGE THAT. THIS
DISTANCE PROHIBITED TO PARK. OF
MEETING. SPECIAL SINCE THE
SUPERVISORS MAY IN THE MIDDLE
WORK DAY. TUESDAY ANY.
CORPORATE COMMUNITY OF ABOUT
THAT. READ THE TROUBLE IN OUR A
HALF TO THE COUNTY MEETINGS
THAT HELD RIVER. EITHER JUST AT
THE EXAMPLE OF BROKEN. THAT TO
PROTECT IN COVER. BUT THE- IN
THE- CREDIT. IT IS EVEN MORE.
FOR PEOPLE WHO RELY PUBLIC.
HE'S COMMITTEE COMMUNITIES.
WILL BE ABLE TO PROTECT.
REMOTELY UNDER EIGHTY THREE.
NINE THAT INCLUDES THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED AMENDMENT.
THE COMMUNITIES A FAIR. LAVIGNE
MADERA COUNTY AND COUNTLESS
BARTLETT. EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE
THE SAME ACT TO PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. PARENTS WISHING
TO PARTICIPATE IN SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS REMOTELY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO SO. COMMUNITY
LEADERS WISHING TO PARTICIPATE
IN COUNCIL THE GOVERNMENT
PLANNING COMMISSION SIMPLY
CICADELLIDAE COMMISSION FAMILY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO SO. THE
CANADIAN AMENDMENT CHALLENGE
THE BASIC PRINCIPLE THAT
GOVERNMENT MIGHT BE ACCEPTABLE
TO ALL. THE ACT IF YOU'RE
ELECTED OFFICIALS AS A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT. WE ARE
DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED WITH THE
COMMITTEES INSISTENCE ON
AMENDMENTS THAT SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE THE PROPOSED EXTENSION
OF PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. WE
BELIEVE THAT EIGHTY THREE
THIRTY NINE SHOULD BE BUILT
UPON AND EXPANDED TO ENCOMPASS
ALL GOVERNMENT MEETINGS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE- URGE THE
COMMITTEE. TO CONTINUE TOWARDS
THE STATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW BONNIE LEE.
PLEASE GET AFTER- CHAIRMAN
MA'AM. MY NAME IS BONNIE AND I
AM A POOR TRUST WITH THE SAN
CLARITA SCHOOL. I AM SPEAKING
TO YOU TO TAKE ON MY OWN BEHALF
I AM SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TODAY AS A LOCAL
ELECTED WHO HAS SEEN A DRASTIC
INCREASE IN PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AND ENGAGEMENT IN
OUR MEETINGS TO RESUME. THIS
BILL IS TIMELY AND VERY MUCH
NEEDED TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY. AND ACCESSIBILITY
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. I'M
AWARE THAT THE AUTHOR HAS TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT THE
APPLICATION OF THIS BILL TO
CITY COUNCILS. AND BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ONLY BUT I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THIS INITIATIVE
CAN LATER EXPAND. TO INCLUDE
MORE LOCAL AGENCIES SUCH A
SCHOOL BOARD. AS A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER I OFTEN WORK WITH
PARENTS WHO ARE UNABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR MEETINGS
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT TRAVEL OR
FIND CHILD CARE OPTIONS FOR
MEETINGS THAT MAY GO ON FOR
SEVERAL HOURS. CONSTITUENTS
NEED A WAY TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES AFTER ELECTIONS.
BECAUSE NOT EVERYONE HAS TIME
TO DRIVE TO SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS OR CITY COUNCIL
MEETINGS AND SIT THERE FOR FIVE
HOURS. I LOCAL ELECTED SO THE
ONLY WAY WE CAN HAVE A
FUNCTIONING GOVERNMENT IS WHEN
WE HAVE PUBLIC INVOLVEMENT AND
THEN WHEN OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
EDUCATED ON THE ISSUES. DURING
THIS PANDEMIC WE'VE BEEN
REQUIRED TO FIND ALTERNATIVE
METHODS TO ENGAGE THE PUBLIC.
WHICH HAS INCLUDED THE MEETINGS.
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC REGULAR
IN PERSON BOARD MEETINGS WOULD
ATTRACT MAYBE A DOZEN MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. DURING THE
PANDEMIC THANKS TO LIVE STREAM
AND RELATED PUBLIC ACCESS BE A
WEAPON ARE IN TELEPHONE I'VE
SEEN UP TO A TEN X. INCREASE IN
PARTICIPATION BECAUSE WE ALLOW
REMOTE PARTICIPATION OPTION
THROUGH OPTIONS LIKE ZOOM WHICH
HAS BEEN CRITICAL AND ENGAGING
PARENTS WHILE DISCUSSING REMOTE
EDUCATION. AND THE SAY FREE
OPENING OF OUR SCHOOLS. DUE TO
REMOTE PARTICIPATION WE NOW SEE
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TUNED INTO
OUR LIVE STREAMS WITH ANOTHER
EIGHT HUNDRED PEOPLE WHO WATCH
THE LIVE STREAM AFTER WE ARE.
ADJOURNED I'VE ALSO HEARD
FEEDBACK ABOUT HOW THE PUBLIC
HAS SEEN A LOT OF DOORS OPEN
FOR THEM TO ENGAGE CIVICALLY.
AND MAKE THEIR VOICES HEARD
SUCH AS I REALLY HOPE YOU
CONTINUE OFFERING VIRTUAL
PARTICIPATION IN BOARD MEETINGS
BECAUSE I CAN'T ATTEND IN
PERSON. AND BEING ABLE TO
ATTEND MEETINGS VIRTUALLY HAS
HELPED ME BE BETTER INFORMED
ABOUT THE GOINGS ON IN THE
DISTRICT. I KNOW A LOT OF LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE COST OF IMPLEMENTATION. BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
WE'VE ALREADY FOUND WAYS TO
IMPLEMENT TECHNOLOGY AND THE
INCREASED AVENUES OF
PARTICIPATION ARE WELL WORTH IT.
SAMPLE IT'S FREE TO LIVE
STREAMING MEETING FROM YOUR
PHONE TO YOU TOO. SO THERE ARE
WAYS TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
SUBSTANTIATED WITH THIS
TECHNOLOGY. AND MONEY SHOULD
NOT BE AN ISSUE WHEN IT COMES
TO INVOLVING THE PUBLIC. HAS
ELECTED OFFICIALS WE SHOULD
ALWAYS BE LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
INCREASE OUR OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT WITH MEMBERS OF THE
pGREAT STEP IN THAT DIRECTION.
ONE GOOD THING THAT HAS COME
FROM THE PANDEMIC IS THE
INCREASING PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND THE
AUTHORS MISSION OF INCREASING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THERE'S NONE IN THE GALLERY- A.
T. AND T. OPERATOR. AB THREE
WISHES IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THREE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY IN
Q. FOUR VIRTUAL LINE THAT'S
THREE SIX NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS JACK BUILDING
BILL RATE THIRTY COUNCIL MEMBER
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. RIGHT
FOR EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TONY TRIGGER- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. FOUR
EIGHT EIGHT FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
GREEN A LIGHTER WITH THE CHILD
CARE LAWCENTER AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THREE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
QUE WHEN BEING LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH A SO YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTION PROUD CO
SPONSOR THREE THREE NINE ALSO
READING CONSOLIDATED ME TO
SUPPORT ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS I THINK THE
SAME CALIFORNIANS AWARE J. HOT
ACTION CENTRAL VALLEY UNITED
FOR POWER THANKS A LOT FOR
NEARLY ADVOCACY SERVICES INK
CHILDCARE LAWCENTER COURAGE
CALIFORNIA SHAPINGTHE VALLEY
FIRST AMENDMENT COALITION
FRESNO METRO BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. KAMAN CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS AMONG INNOVATING
POLITICS HOUSING IS. A HUMAN
RIGHT ORANGE CALIFORNIA.
INDIVISIBLE GREEN TEAM
INDIVISIBLE BAY INDIVISIBLE
STANISLAUS LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA. LOW
MULLIN THE UNIVERSITY NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA ORANGE COUNTY
QUALITY COALITION PEOPLE BUDGET
PHILIPPINE PEOPLE COLLECT THEIR
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
PUBLIC ADVOCATES SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY BOARD OF ED AREA BE.
SPECIAL EDUCATION ADVOCATE
LEADERS SENIOR IN DISABILITY
ACTION THE PEOPLE COLLECTED FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. TIME FOR
CHANGE FOUNDATION TOGETHER WE
WILL INDIVISIBLE LOS GATOS
VOICES FOR PROGRESS WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY YOU
JUSTICE EDUCATION CLINIC
BOYLAND LAW SCHOOL AND JAMIE
LAREAU AS AN INDIVIDUAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THAT GOING FOR IT ALAMEDA FOR
EVERYONE AND- IN THE ACTION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
NINETY NINE THIRTY THREE HI AND
IT CURRENT AUTOMATIC FOR THANK
YOU. YEAH. FIVE FIVE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE ONE TWO.
NINE FIVE OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M OUT A
BOOK WRITER I AM A PLANNING
COMMISSIONER CITY OF CAMPBELL
AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
EIGHT NEXT COURT EIGHTY THREE
THREE NINE THE CARD AMENDED
FORM THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THE ERROR ARE SOME WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
YOU HAVEN'T TAKEN A POSITION
YET ON THE BILL- BUT WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE AND MAKE SURE
THAT- THAT THE- MEETINGS ARE
ONLY ACCESSIBLE FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NINE FIVE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI HI MY NAME IS
EMILY AND ROBERT OKAY I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THREE NINE I AM A CURRENT A
RENTAL HOUSING COMMITTEE MEMBER
IN THE CITY O MOUNTAIN VIEW
ALTHOUGH I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF AND OF MOUNTAIN VIEW
GIMME THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIND FIVE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS NOW CURRENTLY I LIVE IN
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA ALTHOUGH IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIVE OR
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MOM HOW
ALSO WITH AN ANSWER FOR
EVERYONE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB THREE THREE NINE AS IT IS
STAND CURRENTLY. THANK YOU.
FIVE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MARK ON THE HALF THE
TOWN ON PROFITS IN SUPPORT OF
THAT CURRENT APRIL FIFTEENTH
PERSON. THANK YOU I HAVE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. J.
CREMIN OWNERS BURKE I. T. AND
LIKE A DIRECTOR OF KALAMAZOO
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICT AND
THE LAPTOP COMMISSIONER
REPRESENTING MYSELF THOUGH NOT
THOSE LAST TWO ENTITIES CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
FIVE FOURTEEN THREE FOUR HAD.
GIVE ME FAN OF NUMBER THIRTY OF
DOWNEY BLUNDER PRESS A NEUTRAL
POSITION WITH THE PROPOSED
MONDAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FOUR NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
KARINA GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
HIM AND CLIMATE SOLUTIONS AND
FROM SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FIVE
TO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CHARLES WHITFIELD SAN FRANCISCO
RESIDENT AND GIVE THE ACTUAL
NUMBER- IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THREE NINE IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
THANKS THANK YOU. FIVE CAN YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MORAL ABOUT
SENDING- INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA
STATE STRONG A GROUP OF EIGHTY
ONE INDIVISIBLE CHAPTERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIVE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS IT'S A CORD WITH GIVE YOU
ACTION EAST BAY- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE ORIGINAL OR THE
CURRENT VERSION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FIVE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS MARIA
AREAS AND REPRESENTING THE YOU
TUBE MOMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE NINE. THANK YOU.
FIVE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS ELIZABETH HANDS
BURKE I'M THE CHAIR OF THE
PLANNING COMMISSION IN THE CITY
OF FULLERTON AND I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT I SUPPORTED- WITH.
IN AND SHOULD APPLY TO ALL ALL
PUBLIC BODIES- IN MY EXPERIENCE
AS A CLINICAL RESEARCH. THANK
YOU. FOUR NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MARY AND GROWTH
NEAR- WITH SPECIAL EDUCATION
ADVOCATE LEADER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE NINE.
THANK YOU. FIVE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS RYAN OLSEN
I'M WITH I'M A MEMBER OF
ABUNDANT HOUSING LA YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE DIED
IN ITS CURRENT FORM THANK YOU.
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THE RECORD LIVERMORE
RESIDENT INDIAN B. ACTION
MEMBER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE NINE IN ITS CURRENT
UNAMENDED FORM THANK YOU. FIVE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND YOU
KNOW LEADING WITH THE MOST BAY
AREA PRINTER CALTRAIN AND
ALTHOUGH I'M A MEMBER OF- MEMO
PARK COMPLETE COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FIVE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS RHONDA CONNELL CALLING
FROM NAPA AS A MEMBER OF YOU BE
ACTION AND HOW TO LEAD YOU IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE NINE
THANK YOU. FIVE THIRTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MERRY
CREEPY AND THE HALF OF THE
CHILDREN PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE THREE NINE. THANK
YOU. FIVE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS EMILY
CRONIN COMPLETELY CALIFORNIA
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE. THE BILL WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THANK YOU. FIVE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN HEAR
ME. YES AB LARA CALLING FROM
YOU IN THE ACTION- TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE AMAZING
FEATURES OF BEING ABLE TO DIAL
IN REMOTELY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB THREE THREE NINE THANK
YOU. FIVE A ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS LINDA CHANG FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. FIVE THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I AM CALLED FROM LOS
ALTOS STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI COUNTY BEING FROM
PALO ALTO- CALLING THE
PENINSULA FOR EVERYONE IN THE
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THREE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS ONE FROM
BENDIGO CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE THREE NINE THANK YOU.
FIVE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE POINT. SORRY I'M
EXPRESSING MY STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
DEMOCRATS- THE OFFICIAL STUDENT
WING OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
B. ZHAN- MERRY ARE. FOR THE
LEVY CALIFORNIA'S CITIES AND
JEFF NEAL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
YES MADAM CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BE JAN
MARY OUR LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE THREE
NINE I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR- AND
POPCORN OUT OF THIS BILL AND I
ALSO THINK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS FOR THEIR GRACIOUSNESS
IN HEARING OUT OUR CONCERNS. WE
ARE STILL EVALUATING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT PROPOSED THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THEM IN
CRAMPED- CALPERS CITY IS DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCESS. THAT IS WHY WE WROTE
AND SPONSORED THE BROWN ACT
ALMOST SEVENTY YEARS AGO. YEAH
NOW GIVEN THE SURGE OF INTEREST
IN THE BROWN ACT THEIR TO
BROADER ISSUES BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THE FIRST IS
THAT EVEN IF THE BILL IS
AMENDED OUT OF CLOTHES. THIS
WILL STILL CREATE A HIGHER
STANDARD THAT IS ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT STATE AGENCIES AND
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ONE THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY IS LIFTED. THIS
DOUBLE STANDARD REMAINS
TROUBLING TO THE THOUSANDS OF
PUBLIC AGENCIES REPRESENTED IN
OUR COALITION. SECOND OF THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS WHAT
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT MEETINGS IN
THE FUTURE FOR LOCAL PUBLIC
AGENCIES. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
THINK IN TERMS OF EITHER THE
MINISTRATION. UNIFORMITY ACROSS
AGENCIES AND ALSO HOW WE CAN
BEST FUTURE PROOF ARE CHANGES
TO THE LAW SO WE ARE NOT
REVISITING THE STANDARD EVERY
COUPLE OF YEARS. WE ARE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR YOU
SHARE THE LEARNED EXPERIENCES
OF OUR AGENCIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND DISCUSS HOW THOSE
EXPERIENCES CAN BETTER INFORM
THE LEGISLATURE'S POLICY
DELIBERATIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW WE ARE
LOOKING FOR JEFF NEAL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JEFF NEAL HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. THEM GONNA SPEND ALL
YEAR HI COUNTY BEEN TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE BEST WAY TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC ACCESS AND
BALLENSTEDT ACCESS WITH THE
PRACTICAL REQUIREMENTS OF
GOVERNING AND FRANKLY THE
SAFETY OF PUBLIC OFFICIALS- AS
ALL OF US HERE NO IT'S HARD TO
DO THAT THE LEGISLATURE TO
HELP. WITH ITS SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES HAS STRUGGLED WITH
THE SAME PROBLEMS NOT ONLY
BALANCING ACCESS WITH SAFETY
BUT BUT EVEN JUST THE
MECHANICAL IMPLEMENTATION WHICH
WE ALL REALIZE WITHIN ART AND-
ARE PROMPTING DESPITE. PATIENCE
AND PROFESSIONALISM OF EVERYONE
INVOLVED SO- YOU CREATE THE
DIRECTION OF THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE- AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO LOOKING AT
THE MONITOR AND PRINTED
EVALUATING OUR POSITION POINTED
FORWARD- I DO WONDER IF NOW
THAT THE BILL'S REQUIREMENT TO
BE SCALED BACK IT MIGHT BE
WORTH. RECONSIDERING WHETHER
ADDITION APPLY TO IMPORTANT AND
FOR PEOPLE DISTANT STATE
AGENCIES LIKE THE P. C. A. R.
B. THE COAST COMMISSION AND
OTHERS- I DO WANNA THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR TO YOUR ATTENTION
TO THIS BILL AND THANKS
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
AS WELL THOROUGH ANALYSIS AND-
AND TO THE SPONSORS FOR- AND
DOCTOR FOR THEIR- PRODUCTIVE.
AND RESPECTFUL. BEATS THANK YOU.
THANK ARE ANY OTHER WITNESS AND
UP. I NONE OF THE GAL. OPERATOR
WITNESSES AND IN OPPOSITION. TO
AB. THREE THREE NINE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY THREE
THREE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT NINE IN Q. WE'LL GO
TO LINE UP FIVE OH SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE NEW ABOUT THAT
HEIGHTEN THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
AND WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION AND APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT THANK YOU. FIVE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BIRDS
PROPOSED GET UP ON BEHALF OF
THE PUBLIC RISK INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS AND MANAGEMENT OFTEN
ARE NOT PRESENT IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DILLON GIBBONS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION WITH THE
MEMBERS ACCEPTED BY THE AUTHOR
WE ANTICIPATE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION AND I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THE AUTHOR THE STAFF MADAM
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE STEP
WE'RE WORKING WITH US TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS. THANK YOU.
FOUR SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHRIS ANDERSON I'LL BE HAPPY
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION WILL BE
EVALUATING THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. FOUR FIFTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JEAN
HURST CALLING IN TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTY THE
CALIFORNIA AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AT BOTH ORGANIZATIONS ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL WE DO
APPRECIATE- THE DILIGENT WORK
OF THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE AUTHOR AND HIT
HIM. ON THE AMENDMENTS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THEM THANK
YOU THANK YOU. FOUR NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
IN BREAKING WITH AND CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT- ALSO HERE
WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
LOOKING OVER THE AND THEN THEN
CAN THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
CHAIR AND STAFF FOR ALL OF
THEIR WORK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. FIVE FORTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE FOUR TWO. THREE
EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NOTHING NOT INSURANCE MEMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON THE COASTLINE
OF COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND
PRINT EXTREMELY THANKFUL FOR
THE AMENDMENTS AND WILL REVISIT
THE POSITION AFTER THAT PART OF
HAVING A CHANCE TO LOOK AT IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FOUR
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS A BOB TAYLOR ON
BEHALF OF THE TRANSPORTATION
CORRIDOR AGENCIES AND OF THOSE
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY TOLL ROADS
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN
PRINT AND WILL REVIEW THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIVE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT CARE NUMBERS JASON BRYANT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR THE
COMMITTEE AND CHAIRWOMAN- BASED
ON THE IMPACT MANY AMENDMENTS
OFFERED ANY ANALYSIS- WE
ANTICIPATE BEING ABLE TO REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR OR
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE I
BELIEVE WE HAVE THE HI WE ARE
MOTION IN THE SECOND SO I THINK
IT WAS OF- ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONE
HARM THE PERFECT VISIT THE
DENTIST. AND THE SECOND BY
RUSSIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS. ALL RIGHT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER LEE
YEAH I WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK
AGAIN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
CHAIR FOR THE WORK ON THIS AND
I THINK IT'S A RARE WE GET TO
DEBATE A POLICY THAT IS
INACTION AS WE SPEAK AT THE
VERY MOMENT I THINK THE
SILVERLINE OF ENDEMIC IS SHOWN
THAT GOVERNMENTS CAN BE MORE
CLOSELY USING THE MARKET
KNOWLEDGE WE HAVE AND- AS
EVIDENCE TODAY MEANS A LOT TO
LOT OF PEOPLE. I EVEN THINK
BACK TO HOW MANY POSITIONS OF
MINE ENGAGE IN THEIR FIRST CITY
COUNCIL BEING OR SCHOOL BOARD
MEETING BECAUSE THEY'RE ABLE TO
DO SO NOW WITHOUT THE ANT BE
INTIMIDATING ATMOSPHERE HAVING
TO GO TO CITY HALL OR GO TO A
CERTAIN PLACE AND TESTIFIED- IT
MEANS A LOT I THINK AND WILL
HOPEFULLY REAL RESHAPE OUR
GOVERNMENT IF WE HEAR MORE
VOICES. AND I'M VERY MUCH
COMMITTED TO CONTINUED WHAT
THIS WORK AND MAKING SURE WE
HAVE MORE TRANSPARENCY WE HAVE
MORTGAGE AT ALL LEVEL I SEE A
LOT OF THE SENTIMENT OF MANY OF
OUR SPEAKERS THAT I WISH YES IT
WAS UNIFORM ACROSS ALL.
AGENCIES AND BODIES BUT I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
SIGNIFICANT STEP AND SOMETIMES
CHANGE IS DIFFICULT AND IT WILL
HOPEFULLY THIS BILL WILL BE
ABLE TO PROVE THE CONCEPT THAT
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW IS VIABLE IN
THE LONG TERM ON WITH WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY OR DRIVING.
HELLO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE AND I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS TODAY AND I. I THINK
YOU DID SAY THAT YOU'RE TAKING
AMENDMENTS- BUT BECAUSE WE
SHARE A VERY STRONG BELIEF IN
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT
GOVERNMENT. WE ALSO BOTH SEE
THE BENEFITS OF REMOTE REMOTE
ACCESS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MEETINGS FOR PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE SCOPE. COST AND
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY OUR FELLOW
LAWMAKERS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. I
DO REMAIN WORRIED ABOUT SOME OF
THE BILL'S NEW REQUIREMENTS I
DO NOT QUESTION THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN CRAFTED WITH THE BEST
INTENTIONS. TO INCREASE ACCESS
FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCEEDINGS
OF THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AND
WHO FACE BARRIERS TO ACTIVE
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT. BUT I HOPE
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
POSSIBLE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD. I HOPE YOU'LL ALWAYS I
HOPE YOU WILL FIND WAYS TO
CLOSE AVENUES FOR BAD ACTORS TO
STYMIE EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
LOCAL MEETINGS OR FINAL LEGAL
LOOPHOLES TO NULLIFY
GOVERNMENT. DECISIONS I
AGREEING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ADVOCATES APPLYING THESE NEW
RULES TO OUR LOCAL AGENCIES
WHILE EXEMPTING STATE AGENCIES
AND THE LEGISLATURE. IS ONE
MORE REASON FOR PEOPLE TO FEEL
CYNICAL ABOUT WHAT WE DO HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. IF THIS IS SUCH
AN IMPORTANT DEVELOPMENT FOR
DEMOCRACY. AND WE FEEL IT IS
ATTAINABLE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HOW DO WE EXEMPT
OURSELVES. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS THE
REMAINING CONCERNS WITH THEIR
ABILITY TO COMPLY WITH THE
BILL. BOTH FINANCIALLY AND LIKE
JUST LIKE JUST TO CLICK. AND TO
BE HELD HARMLESS FOR
NONCOMPLIANCE IF THEY MAKE GOOD
FAITH EFFORTS TO COMPLY. WITH
THE AMENDMENTS I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY AND
LOOK FORWARD TO PROGRESS IS THE
BILL MARK MOVES FORWARD- MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I.
LACKEY. MOON I LOU I BURNER.
RAMOS THREE OF US THREE OF US
FIVE ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL. HI YOU HAVE
FIVE ZERO. HI YEAH. I YEAH. ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAMES. THANK
YOU AND I THINK YOU I WILL-
TAKE THE AS CUT SOME MIKE-
SHORT- YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY HAS ABOUT TODAY
ON AB FIVE SEVENTY ONE I WILL
BE ACCEPTING- THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS HI THIS LEGISLATION
IS JUST ONE SMALL PIECE THE
LARGER PUSH TO MAKE HOUSING
MORE AFFORDABLE. IN CALIFORNIA.
IMPACTING VELLUM THE FEES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNDER
DENSITY BONUS LAW CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECT. THE
OVERALL COST OF THE PROJECT AND
ARE OFTEN PASSED ALONG TO
BUYERS. IN THE FORM OF HIGHER
HOME PRICES OR PREVENT PROJECTS
FROM GOING FORWARD. THAT IS WHY
THIS LEGISLATION SIMPLY
PROHIBITS IMPOSING CERTAIN FEES
FOR DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
UNITS. IT SIMPLY DOES NOT MAKE
SENSE TO DIS INCENTIVIZE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE UNITS. WITH A
DENSITY BONUS APPLICATION AS WE
SEEK TO ENCOURAGE DEVELOPERS TO
MAXIMIZE AFFORDABLE UNITS. I
WITH THAT ABOUT INTRODUCED
JENNIFER SPEC WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION REALTORS
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE LOOKING FOR
PREFERRED JENNIFER BACK. HI
LINE IS OPEN BOTTOM HELLO MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER SPECTRUM HI HOW ARE
YOU JENNIFER SPOKE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS PROP ONTO THE BABY
FIVE SEVENTY ONE WHICH SEEKS TO
CREATE MORE UNITS OF NATURALLY
OCCURRING AFFORDABLE MARKET
RATE HOUSING WHILE ALSO SEEKING
TO INCREASE AND MAXIMIZE THE
NUMBER OF DEALERSHIPS
AFFORDABLE UNITS. CONTAINED
WITHIN A DENSELY BONTA
PUBLICATION REMOVING THOSE
PEOPLE COULD BE WILL MOVE US IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AS WE SEEK
TO ENACT POLICIES UP SOLVE OUR
STATE PERSISTENT ONGOING-
HOUSING CRISIS AS WELL AS
CREATE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
US TO. SOLVE THE STATE'S THAT
PERSISTENT MARKUPS WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR EITHER. THANK YOU ARE
THERE OTHER WITH THIS ISN'T THE
I SEE NINETY THE GALLERY ON
THIRTY. OTHER ON OF THE PHONE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR. THIS IS
ON US AB FIVE SEVEN ONE. THANK
YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE SEVEN ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN Q.
WILL GO TO ONE THREE NINE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT HAPPENING
JERRY NUMBERS DOESN'T MATTER
THAT WAY HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
GREENBELT ALLIANCE COULD NOT BE
ONLINE TODAY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
FIVE FOUR FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS KELLY CALLING
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE DAIRY
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT FIVE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
KIMBERLY DONE BUT THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
FIVE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LEVINE ALLIANCE FOR SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DON'T CARE
THIS IS BOB DALY REPRESENTING
FEELS SEVEN COMPANY AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS FINE BILL. KIM
THANK YOU RIDE FIVE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS WARRANTED OLYMPIA
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR WE'LL NOW LOOK
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FIVE FIVE SEVEN ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. FIVE THREE NINE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN
BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE WE HAVE
A BOMB MOTION AND A SECOND
ALREADY I BELIEVE. WE'RE GOOD
TO GO ON THAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL WAS USED. TO THE MOTION
TO AFFECT. TENTH MEMBER
THREE OF US ON SECOND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER- JUST
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND
I WILL- THANK YOU. FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FOR IT- THAT THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
TO CLARIFY THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL. PLACING ENCLOSURE IFFY
INCLUSIONARY FEES ON MARKET
RATE UNITS IS A GOOD WAY TO
FUND AND SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS. YOUR BILL
ENSURES THAT AFFORDABLE UNITS
THEMSELVES ARE NOT ALSO CHARGE
INCLUSIONARY FEES THISIS A
COMMONSENSE POLICY AND I AM%
PLEASED TO SUPPORTERS TODAY.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. A FOR ME AS
WELL AS AMENDED SORRY DID YOU
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I.
LACKEY BLOOM I WILL PROVIDE
BOERNER HORVATH RAMOS HI WELL
THOSE ARE THOSE RIVAS WAS
REVERSED HI ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVERSIDE HOTEL. HI CAN HELP
ALL RIGHT. YEAH SIX ZERO IF
ZERO THANK YOU YOU'RE VERY
WELCOME- LET'S MOVE ON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MOMENT AND
IF YOU'D LIKE TO FOLLOW WITH
YOUR BILL- WELL I'M OPEN TO
THAT. I'LL BEGIN WITH A AB TEN
TWENTY NINE THAT'S- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLINS BILL ON
PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WERE ALL AWARE OF THE
MASSIVE SHORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE STATE. ON THE
LESSER KNOWN CONTRIBUTORS TO
THE ISSUE IS THE EXPIRATION OF
SO CALLED AFFORDABILITY
COVENANTS. WHEN CALIFORNIA HAD
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS THAT
RECEIVE FUNDING FROM THE AGENCY
WERE REQUIRED TO RECORD
COVENANTS ON THE PROPERTY THAT
WOULD GUARANTEE THAT THOSE
UNITS WOULD REMAIN AFFORDABLE.
AT BELOW MARKET RATES FOR
THIRTY AND IN SOME INSTANCES
FIFTY YEARS. AS TIME PASSES
MANY OF THOSE COVENANTS REACH
THERE ARE TIME LIMITS AND
EXPIRE. AS THOSE TIME LIMITS
EXPIRE THE UNIT MAY THEM BE
LEASED AT MARKET RATE. AS EACH
UNIT RESETS TO MARKET RATE
THAT'S ONE LESS AFFORDABLE UNIT
THAT IS AVAILABLE TO A LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. AB TEN
TWENTY NINE SIMPLY ASK THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. TO ADD
PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE
UNITS TO THEIR LIST OF
PRIORITIES FOR ALLOCATION OF
FUNDING. IT'S MUCH EASIER TO
SAVE UNIT FROM CONVERTING TO
MARKET RATE THAN TO BUILD A
BRAND NEW UNIT THIS IS A SIMPLE
YET IMPORTANT STEP TO MAINTAIN
CALIFORNIA'S. SCARCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING STOCK. WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. ON THE
PHONE TODAY ARE SHERMAN'S
OFFICE TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF FOSTER CITY AND
BARBARA GROSS STUDY RETIRED
RESIDENT OF FOSTER'S LANDING
WHICH IS EIGHT RENTAL HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT WHICH SEVENTY FOUR
UNITS. WILL SOON BE LOSING
THEIR AFFORDABILITY COVENANTS.
THANK YOU OPERATOR- WE'RE
LOOKING FOR MISS CONVOLVULUS OR
MISS GROVE CITY. THANK YOU BOTH
FIND ARE OPEN. HI AND CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK YES WE CAN THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS SHARING
THE BALL THEN WITH THE READING
PUBLIC POLICY GROUP YOU'RE A
DEFINING TODAY. ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF FOSTER CITY WHICH
IS LOCATED IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MONIQUE DISTRACT. LET ME BEGIN
BY THANKING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN FOR CARING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION IN
THINKING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
POLITICAL PROVIDING TODAY. HE
FOSTER. WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
DAMAGE OUR COMMITMENT TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND ARE
PROUD TO BE IN THE TOP 5% OF
CITIES IN THE STATE. IT COMES
TO MEETING OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TARGETS. ONE OF THE
CITY'S EXISTING. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS FOSTER
LANDING MYSELF IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES. AND IT INCLUDED
SEVENTY FOUR BELOW MARKET RATE
RENTAL UNITS. THE PMR
RESTRICTIONS WERE SET TO EXPIRE
IN PHASES STARTING WITH FIFTY
UNITS EXPIRING AT THE END OF
LAST YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND
THE FINAL STATE EXPIRING BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
MORE THAN FIFTY UNITS THAT WERE
SET TO EXPIRE LAST YEAR THE
CITY AND THE PROPERTY OWNER
AGREED TO EXTEND THE AFFORDABLE
RENTS TO THE FAKE ONE TENANT
UNTIL DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF
THAT YEAR. THE CITY ALLOCATED
FUNDS TO PAY ITS SHARE OF THIS
PROGRAM. HOWEVER AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR THE RESIDENTS IN THE
BMR UNITS THAT POSSIBLY ENDING
WILL SEE THEIR MONTHLY RENT
INCREASE FROM FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO APPROXIMATELY.
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS. BOB
CITY HAS TAKEN SEVERAL STEPS TO
ASSIST THE TENANTS OF POSSIBLY
ENDING. AND ALL RESIDENTS IN
OUR CITY WHO LIVE IN OR ARE
LOOKING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE AREA ALL
HAVE EXTREMELY LOW TURNOVER AND
HAVE VERY LONG WAITING LIST
SOME UP TO THREE YEARS. AB TEN
TWENTY NINE WOULD BETTER
POSITION FOSTER CITY TO COMPETE
FOR FUND THROUGH THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM. IN AN
EFFORT TO SECURE A LONG TERM
FUNDING SOURCE FOR FOSTER
COMMUNITY. FOSTER LANDING IS
NOT A FOR FOSTER CITY IS NOT
ALONE IN GRAPPLING WITH THE
POTENTIAL LOSS OF EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT THAT WAS
RELEASED BY EACH CD IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
EXPAND EXPIRING COVENANTS
SUPPORTING KALRA. OVER A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS ACROSS
THE STATE ARE SET TO EXPIRE.
THIS IS LIKELY TO DISPLACE
ALTHOUGH THE RESIDENTS AT UNITS
CONVERTED TO MARKET RATE. WELL
HOUSING PRODUCTION IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN ADDRESSING
THE HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR STATE
THE PRESERVATION OF EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IS AN
EQUALLY IMPORTANT COMPONENTS IN
ENSURING OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS ARE NOT DISPLACED. I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE
EFFORTS MADE ON BEHALF OF
FOSTER CITY AND I HEARD YOUR
AYE VOTE TWENTY TEN TWENTY
NINE. THANK YOU. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS FOR
EVERYBODY WELL I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
PRINTED EVEN IF THE COURT
LEGISLATION THAT WILL HELP
HOMELESSNESS INTOXICATED I HAVE
BEEN A RESIDENTS PARKING
AVAILABLE FOR YOU I'M A
RESIDENT OF POSSIBILITY FOR
OVER FORTY FIVE YEARS. THE
MARKET INFLATED I WAS NO LONGER
ABLE TO PAY MARKET RATE WILL
LEAD ME TO THE BELOW MARKET
RATE APARTMENTS I WAS VERY
FORTUNATE MOVE INTO AN
APARTMENT ARE POSSIBLE BECAUSE
AFTER BEING ON WAITLIST VISIT
SOON. MANY OF THE RESIDENTS ARE
SEEING WHAT MYSELF AND ALSO FOR
THE FAMILIES MEMBERS WITH
DISABILITIES AND MANY FROM BOTH.
PARENTS AT THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE BLACK
MARKET RATE RESIDENTS. WERE
PROVIDED A MOTIVE THE COVER
AFTER WILL PROVIDE FOOD FOR. ON
OUR HOUSE WOULD BE GOING FOR
MARKET RATE. AS SHARON SAID
INCREASE IN OUR RECORD MUCH AS
THREE HUNDRED FOR. IF YOU SHORT
MONTHS LATER THE ENTIRE FOUND
THEMSELVES IN THE MIDDLE THE
CAMP. AND IT ALREADY TROUBLING.
WITHIN DEFICIT THE NUMBER OF.
THANKFULLY THE CITY OF LOS CITY.
ALONG THOSE THANK YOU IN THE
GREEN HELLO NAMES SAVE. NO YOU
HI. EVEN WITH ME VERY YEAR ARE
TO THE VERY PLEASED. CURRENTLY
AFFORDABLE UNITS IN THE HAVE
WAY LISTS. ABSOLUTELY THE
DEFENDANT. AS PRESIDENT OF THE
THAT WE- FIFTY GO TO OTHER
THINGS LOOK. WILL PUT ON A LOT
OF HERE. THE OTHER BELOW MARKET
RATE IN FACT YOU HAVING OUT TO
AND THEY PUT OUT THE TOP OF
THEIR LIST THE PAIR OF. CURRENT
RATE FOR AFFORD HOUSING A
CRITICAL WE. FOR I'M. CALL HOME
AB TEN TWENTY NINE WILL PROVIDE
CITIES LIKE FOSTER CITY AND
HOUSING DEVELOPERS ANOTHER TOOL
TO ENSURE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STAYS AFFORDABLE I THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY
AND I ENCOURAGE YOUR IDOLS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TEN TWENTY
NINE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN TWENTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
TWO LINES IN Q. EMERGENCY ONE
MOMENT FOR THE FIRST LINE THANK
YOU. FIND FIVE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IT'S HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TEN TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M STRIVE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE FOUR NINE. HELLO
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE CLUB OF
SOUTHWEST ANY PUBLIC POLICY
GROUPS REPRESENTING THE CITIES
OF BELMONT CARLSBAD IN CORONA
IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESS THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS OKAY THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN
TWENTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
SECURE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
AND I HAVE NO. ATTENDEES HERE
IN THE GALLERY AS WELL FOR
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT DO WE
HAVE A C. ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE- WE HAVE
A MOTION. I NEED A MOTION ON
THIS BILL WILL GO SECOND.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN AND- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE- I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR SOME OF US
REMEMBER BLOOM FOR PRESENTING
FOR MR MULLIN TODAY AND THIS
MEANT- THIS BILL HELPS
INCENTIVIZE THE PRESERVATION OF
EXISTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
IN THE FACE OF COVERT AND
ONGOING HOUSING CRISIS I AM
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB TEN
TWENTY NINE TODAY. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI. A LACKEY. LOOM
I WILL HI BURGER OUR BRAVE.
RAMOS HI RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS CYBER PAL OKAY
I'LL KNOW YOU CURRENTLY HAVE
FIVE ONE. RIGHT AB. ONE- THE
RESEARCH INDICATING. OKAY THANK
YOU CURRENTLY HAVE A
JURISDICTION DOES NOT ADOPTED
HOUSING ELEMENT BY THE
STATUTORY DEADLINE IT MUST
ADOPT A EVISED HOUSING ELEMENT
EVERY FOUR YEARS RATHER THAN
EVERY EIGHT THIS PENALTY FOR
NON COMPLIANCE WITH HOUSING
ELEMENT ADOPTION DEADLINES HAS
PROVEN INEFFECTIVE AND LEAD TO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FOR
EXAMPLE UNDER CURRENT LAW A
CITY OR COUNTY CAN ADOPT A
LEGALLY DEFICIENT HOUSING
ELEMENT ALMOST FOUR MONTHS
AFTER THE STATUTORY DEADLINE
WITH NO CONSEQUENCES IN FACT
SOME JURISDICTIONS HAVE ADOPTED
FAULTY DRAFT ELEMENTS BY THE
DEADLINE KNOWING THAT
ADDITIONAL CHANGES AND
REVISIONS WERE NECESSARY TO
COMPLY WITH THE LAW. JUST TO
AVOID A PENALTY OF HAVING TO
REVISE THE ELEMENT IN FOUR
YEARS. IN SOME JURISDICTIONS
THE ADOPTED ELEMENT WAS NOT
REVISED TO CORRECT THE LEGAL
DEFICIENCIES FOR MORE THAN
TWELVE MONTHS AFTER THE
DEADLINE AND IN SOME CASES NOT
FOR YEARS. FOR INSTANCE ONE
CITY ADOPTED A DRAFT ELEMENT IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT HAD FOUND
DID NOT MEET STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. THE CITY TOOK NO
FURTHER ACTION TO REMEDY THE
LEGAL DEFICIENCIES UNTIL TWENTY
NINETEEN FIVE YEARS AFTER THE
CITY WAS ORIGINALLY SUPPOSED TO
ADOPT ITS ELEMENT. AB THIRTEEN
NINETY EIGHT ADDRESSES THESE
PROBLEMS BY CLARIFYING THE LAW
TO REQUIRE ADOPTION OF AN H. C.
D. APPROVED HOUSING ELEMENT BY
THE STATUTORY DEADLINE. THE
BILL ELIMINATES THE FOR YOUR
PENALTY AND INSTEAD PROVIDES
THAT FAILURE TO ADOPT ON TIME
OBLIGATES THE JURISDICTION TO
COMPLETE ANY NECESSARY RESOUNDS
WITHIN ONE YEAR RATHER THAN IN
THE THREE YEARS THAT ARE A LOT
FOR JURISDICTIONS. THAT ADOPT
ON TIME. MY WITNESS TODAY'S
BRIAN A GUSTO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT.
OPERATOR GRAND AUGUSTA THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION SHOULD BE
ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS TRYING TO GET ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA. RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT.
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT. REFORM HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW THE AUTHORS DOWN AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF DESCRIBING
BOTH WHAT THE BILL DOES NOT A
PROBLEM AND ADDRESSES. YOU
THINK IT'S SERVICE TEMPLE
SOLUTION THAT WILL HELP ENSURE
WE GET COMPLIANT HOUSING
ELEMENT. PUT ACTUAL ZONING ON
THE GROUND THAT WE NEED TO GET
AFFORDABLE UNITS FELT HELPLESS
STATE NAVIGATE THAT HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS SO.
LITERATURE I'VE GOTTEN THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ON THE.
PHONE THERE'S NONE IN THE
GALLERY. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I. DO
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE MINUTE HERE
IS THE ONE FOR THE WHY NOT.
THANK YOU. HE PINE FOR THIRTY
TWO GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KAREN MEMBER THANK YOU GOT THE
ON OF WESTERN SENT ON LAW AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NINE IN THE
GALLERY. HE WISHES TO GET
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO
HAVE ONE MINING CURACY ONE
MOMENT FOR THAT RIGHT NUMBER.
NINE FOUR FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS JAMES
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LEADERS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
OKAY I THINK QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. DO WANT O IMITATING
EMOTION WE'LL GO BACK. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NEWS RIVAS HOW WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE- THANK YOU- THIS
BILL I LIKE BECAUSE OF BECAUSE
ALL INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY IN
THE RENEWAL PROCESS. THIS BILL
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT LOCAL
HOUSING ELEMENT FOR TIMELY AND
COMPLIANT WHICH IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURING THAT WE CAN BUILD THE
HOUSING WE NEED TO GET US OUT
OF THIS HOUSING CRISIS. THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THE CLARA FINING
AMENDMENTS THEN PLEASE TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL QUESTION IS
DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY HI. HI LACKEY.
BLOOM HI. I BOERNER HORVATH
RAMOS RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US
THREE BIS FIVE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL. VOEPEL
DOT BODHI. YOU HAVE. FIVE ZERO
FIVE ZERO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NUMBER FOURTEEN- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR AWHILE BEFORE THE
SECOND BEFORE WE GET ON THE
PHONE NUMBER OKAY- THAT COMES.
WE ARE. HI AND WE ARE CURRY I
LACK. BLOOM HI HELLO I BURGER
HARD THAT RAMOS HI LEVELS AS
THREE OF US. HI THIS RIVERSIDE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVERSIDE
HOTEL WITHOUT ADDING DO YOU
HAVE. FIVE ZERO ZERO. THE
FOURTEENTH. FOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR OKAY I DON'T. THANK
YOU MAN CHAIR AND THE FLOODING
IS PRESENT AB HAVE FORKED AT
THIRTEEN OH FOUR AND I'LL BE
BRIEF SINCE ANOTHER COMMITTEES
BEEN HERE FOR A MINUTE AND THIS
IS REALLY JUST TO CLARIFY
ENFORCEMENT AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ON A BILL
PREVIOUSLY SIGNED OTHER WILL
WORK ON WHICH- PERMANENTLY A
FURTHER FAIR HOUSING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND THIS
WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL AGENCIES
AFFIRMATIVELY CONTINUE TO
FURTHER FAIR HOUSING AND IT
WOULD CLARIFY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND MUST ADDRESS RACIAL
INTEGRATION AND SEGREGATION
PATTERNS WAS FAIR HOUSING
ISSUES- THIS WILL ENSURE THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE DRESSING
HOUSING INEQUITIES AND ACTIVELY
PLANNING FOR MORE INTEGRATED
FUTURE HOUSING- IN THE FUTURE
THAT PRIORITIZES A FAIR
HOUSING. AND WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES- ANY RAMOS FROM
PUBLIC ADVOCATES ANYA LAWLER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA RULE LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
PUBLIC INTEREST. LAW PROJECT.
THANK YOU VENTURE. BRADFORD AND
I. LOOKING FOR A WIDER OPEN
OKAY THANK YOU. HELLO HI THERE
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ON THAT'S
ROMMEL'S TESTIFYING ON BEHALF
PUBLIC ADVOCATES. THIS BILL
BUILDS UPON EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
SIX WHICH WAS A FAIR HOUSING
BILL ENACTED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THAT REQUIRES PUBLIC
ENTITIES INCLUDING CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHER FAIR HOUSING IN THEIR
ACTIONS RELATING TO HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. THAT AFH
OBLIGATION IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THE HOUSING AND
DEVELOPMENT DECISIONS ARE
UNDERTAKEN IN A MANNER THAT
DISMANTLES PATTERNS OF
SEGREGATION. HOWEVER STARKLY
DENIED MEANINGFUL HOUSING
CHOICE TO COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. THE
AFH OBLIGATION IS IMPLEMENTED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IN PART
THROUGH A LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HOUSING ELEMENT FOR THE LOCAL
AGENCY IDENTIFIES THE
JURISDICTIONS FAIR HOUSING
ISSUES AND PRIORITIES. AND THEN
LAID OUT ITS STRATEGIES AND
ACTIONS TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
PRIORITIES. SINCE THE ENACTMENT
OF BABY SIX EIGHTY SIX AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE HAVE FOUND
SEVERAL PLACES WHERE THE LAW
NEEDS CLARIFICATION TO ENSURE
THAT CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
MEANINGFULLY IMPLEMENTING PAYER
AFH OBLIGATION. AB THIRTEEN OH
FOUR WILL PROVIDE THOSE
CLARIFICATIONS FOR EXAMPLE THIS
BILL WOULD CLARIFY THE LOCAL
AGENCIES NEED TO LOOK AT HER
HOUSING ISSUES- IN THEIR
JURISDICTION THROUGH BOTH A
LOCAL AND REGIONAL AND- BY
MAKING THESE IMPORTANT
CLARIFICATIONS THIS BILL WILL
ASSIST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. IN
MEETING THEIR FFA COMPLICATION
AND THEREBY EXPAND FAIR HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR
I. BURKE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY WE ANOTHER. WITH US IN
SUPPORT. I GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON THE LAWLER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION A PUBLIC INTEREST
LAW PROJECT AND THE NATIONAL
HOUSING LAW PROJECT- IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME ALL THE ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEGE.
PUBLIC ADVOCATES AND I'LL BE
HERE IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. EXCUSE ME WE HAVE ONE.
ONE OF THE GALLERY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MARCH DIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OPERATOR THERE ANY. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ON THE LINE. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. HAVE
TO IN Q. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FOUR THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IN THE ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY A
PROBLEM COSPONSORED DISPENSER
AND REALLY BURGER AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE ONE MORE WRITING HERE TO
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT
RIGHT NUMBER. NINE FIVE FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
THIS IS ERIC HARRIS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL I SEE NONE IN THE
GALLERY. ON THE LINE. ARE THERE
ANY WAY I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE- LET'S SEE WE HAVE
A MOTION I BELIEVE WE NEED A
MOTION. ON THIS BILL WILL MOVE
THE BILL IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALMOST. SECOND OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BORDER HALLMARK. I'M AND
GET RIGHT. BURNER THE PHONE
NUMBER. TBH THAT'S THE
TECHNICALITIES OF THIS LIVING
RIGHT HERE WE HAVE A FOR SINCE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I THINK
MANAGER TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL FROM COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND YOU KNOW OVER
COMING DECADES OF
DISCRIMINATION UNFAIR HOUSING
POLICIES REQUIRES PROACTIVE
MEASURES ON AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. THAT ARE INVOLVED
IN LOCAL HOUSING DECISIONS YOUR
BILL WILL HELP CLARIFY LOCAL
OBLIGATIONS AND ENSURE THAT
LOCAL AGENCIES WILL TAKE STEPS
TO AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER FAIR
HOUSING AND I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL- MOTIONS TO
DO PASSED INTO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKING. HELLO BOERNER HORVATH
HI BARBARA FIVE ROMMEL'S. RIVAS
HI RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS. VOEPEL
THE BILL NOW WE HAVE FOUR ONE
THANK YOU OKAY WE HAVE FOUR ONE
AS A STANCE RIGHT NOW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A WILL. CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS RELATIVELY SOON.
ALL RIGHT LET'S SORRY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALWAYS HITS ME I SEE A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CREEK SILVA
HERE. GOOD AFTERNOON MISS CREEK
SILVA. AND IT IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER. THIRTEEN TEN SOME BABY
TEN SEVENTEEN WELCOME. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS UP
TODAY I AM PRESENTING RIGHT TO
RESTROOMS ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AS WE KNOW ALL OF US IN
THIS ROOM IN THIS BUILDING CAN
JUST RUN UPSTAIRS OR DOWNSTAIRS
AND USE A RESTROOM WHATEVER WE-
NEED TO. MOST OF US ARE ALL OF
US HAVE HOMES AND IF WE NEED TO
USE THE RESTROOM AT HOME WE CAN
DO THAT AS WELL. BUT FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHICH ARE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE. THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
OPTION. DURING THIS PANDEMIC WE
KNOW THAT NOT ONLY ARE FAST
FOOD RESTAURANTS ARE RETAIL AND
OUR PUBLIC BATHROOMS HAVE BEEN
CLOSED SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS SIMPLY THEY DON'T
HAVE A PLACE TO USE THE
RESTROOM OR TO WASH THEIR HANDS.
AS A COUNTRY AND AS A NATION
AND AS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THIS IS A BASIC BASIC. RIGHT
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOUSING OR
TALKING ABOUT BROADBAND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT EDUCATION IN
SOMETHING AS BASIC AND SANITARY
AS BEING ABLE TO USE A PUBLIC
RESTROOM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN OUR LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES IS ELUSIVE. NOW
IS WERE RE OPENING WE ALSO KNOW
THIS JUST DOES NOT PERTAIN TO
HOMELESSNESS BUT IT ALSO
PERTAINS TO OUR YOUNG ATHLETES
WHO ARE NOW ON BALLER A BALL
PARKS AND TO SENIORS AND OTHERS
WHO SIMPLY WANT TO GO OUTDOORS.
AND USE THE BATHROOM. MANY
LOCAL MUNCIPALITIES HAVE NOT
ONLY LOCKED THEIR BATHROOMS
DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT EVEN
BEFORE THAT. BECAUSE SOMETIMES
THERE ARE THINGS THAT OCCUR IN
BATHROOMS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED WHETHER IT'S
CLEANLINESS WHETHER THERE'S
ISSUES OF SAFETY BUT TO LOCK
BATHROOMS UP FOR CITIZENS AND
FOR OUR PUBLIC IS SIMPLY
SOMETHING THAT IS OCCURRING
MORE OFTEN AND THIS BILL SIMPLY
SAYS LET'S TAKE AN INVENTORY.
LET'S FIND OUT WHAT IS OPEN AND
THAT'S WHAT IT DOES AT THE
LEAST IT COULD AND SHOULD DO
MUCH MORE BUT THIS IS JUST
ABOUT TAKING AN INVENTORY OF
PUBLIC RESTROOMS IN OUR LOCAL
CITIES. SO WITH THAT I DO HAVE
ONE WITNESS. MANDA. SO WE'RE
LOOKING FOR BRADFIELD ALSO
BELIEVE FROM YES ENOUGH IS THAT
CORRECT YES ON THE PHONE.
BUSINESS IN SUPPORT. CURRENTLY
DO NOT SEE BRAD DIALED PRESS
YOUR HOUSE IF YOU ARE ON THE
LINE PLEASE PRESS STAR ZERO SO
I CAN OPEN YOUR LINE. SONOMA
MOTION IN THE SECOND FROM.
BOERNER HORVATH. MISTER
CALDERON HAS ON NOW THANK YOU
HELLO HI WELCOME MISTER
FIELDHOUSE HELLO. BUDGET BEER.
HELLO. YEAH HELLO CAN HEAR ME
YEAH WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE
PROCEED. OKAY MY NAME IS DOCTOR
BROUGHT ABOUT SOME EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND FOUNDER OF THE
NONPROFIT HOMELESS SERVICES
ORGANIZATION CALLED CITY THAT.
WE SERVE AS A PARTNER AND ALLY
TOO MANY LOCAL AND COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS AND ORGANIZATIONS
WITH THE OBJECTIVE OF SERVING.
TO THE BEST OF OUR ABILITY TO
EXPERIENCING THREE LEVEL
HOMELESSNESS WITH THE ULTIMATE
GOAL OF CONNECTING NEIGHBORS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TO
RESOURCES AND HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THE
RESPECTIVE. SYSTEMS OF CARE.
CURRENTLY OPERATING FOR
COUNTIES LOS ANGELES ORANGE
COUNTY RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY. OUR
OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT TEAMS
ALONG WITH OUR COLLECTIVE CASE
MANAGERS. BOB PROVIDE EDUCATION
TO THOSE WE SERVE IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE LATEST INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY HARD. ON US FOR
DISEASE CONTROL WHL IT'S ALL
RECOMMEND FREQUENT HAND WASHING
AND THE PRACTICE OF GOOD
HYGIENE TO COMBAT AND STOP THE
SPREAD OF COPING. NINETEEN
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THE
PROPOSAL I JUST. AB ONE ZERO
ONE SEVEN RIGHT TO RESTROOMS
OCT TWENTY TWENTY ONE. REQUIRES
LOCAL CITY AND COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS TO COMPLETE AN
INVENTORY OF PUBLIC RESTROOMS
AVAILABLE TO HOMELESS
NEIGHBORS. DURING THE COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND SHARE
THEIR FINDINGS WITH THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES. BECAUSE
OF THIS BILL WILL TRULY HELP
THE STATE AND EQUALLY AS
IMPORTANT DON'T THAT. CITY THAT
SERVES TO BE EQUIPPED WITH THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
PROMOTE GOOD HYGIENE STAY SAFE
ESPECIALLY DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. I'M NOT
SITTING AT THE VA OF KINGDOM
CAUSES. WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE ZERO ONE SEVEN AND
EXPRESSED GREAT INTEREST IN
SEEING THIS ASSEMBLY BILL PASS
WHEN IT IS HEARD ON FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT. TWENTY TWENTY ONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THE BABY.
TEN SEVENTEEN. YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE LINE IF
YOU'LL GO TO A LINE OF FOUR
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHAPMAN LEARN SOMETHING
HAPPENED HOUSING CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT FOR AB ONE ZERO ONE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. I ALSO HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINE THREE FIFTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE FIVE
TWO. I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH EITHER ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I SEE
NONE IN THE GALLERY. ANY ON THE
LINE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN SEVENTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR UPON FURTHER ANY
QUESTIONS TO THE COMMITTEE.
DISSING NINE WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM- THIS BOERNER HORVATH YEAH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE HI YES I
WOULD JUST THINK LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS AND ALSO OF WOULD
APPRECIATE AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING AND BE AN ADVOCATE FOR
THE HOMELESS WITH THIS BILL.
MOST OF US NEVER GIVE IT A
SECOND THOUGHT ABOUT OUR
ABILITY TO FIND AND USE THE
RESTROOM FOR HOMELESS
POPULATION THE REALITY IS
STARKLY DIFFERENT. THEY FACE
MANY BARRIERS THAT HOUSED IN
INDIVIDUALS DON'T. THIS BILL IS
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TO ENSURE PEOPLE LIVING ON OUR
STREETS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
BASIC NECESSITIES. A RESTROOM
PROVIDES I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT YOUR BLL TODAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY HI. I.
LACKEY. BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
HI BOERNER HORVATH I ROLES
RAMOS I WAS RIVAS THREE OF US
SIDE ROBERT RIVAS. VOEPEL NO
HELLO YOU HAVE FOUR ONE.
THEREFORE ONE WAY FOR THE REST
OF OUR THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY I THINK WE
HAVE HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL ITEM NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN. AND
YOU CAN FOLLOW IT UP WITH YOUR
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB NINE EIGHTY
NINE IF THAT WORKS FOR YOU SIR.
THAT DOES WORK THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS- PLEASE
REMAIN PRESENT AB SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN WHICH WOULD EMPOWER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PRESERVE MIDDLE
INCOME WORKFORCE HOUSING THIS
IS A CENTRAL TO ADDRESSING OUR
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS AND
ENSURING THAT WORKING FAMILIES
FIREFIGHTERS NURSES TEACHERS
AND POLICE OFFICERS CAN AFFORD
TO LIVE IN THE COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY WORK AND SERVE. AB
SEVENTY SEVEN WOULD ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO RECEIVE ARENA
CREDIT FOR CONVERTING MARKET
RATE UNITS TO DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE UNITS. THIS WILL
INCENTIVIZE THE LONG TERM
PRESERVATION OF LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING.
CARRYING CONVERTING EXISTING
UNITS IS AN IMPORTANT
COMPLEMENT TO ANY PRODUCTION
STRATEGY AND OFFERS A CHEAPER
FASTER AND MORE EFFICIENT WAY
TO INCREASE MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSING YOU COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL SUPPORTED
BY A BROAD COALITION THAT
INCLUDES THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IN THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE SCOTT
CARPER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY HOUSING AGENCY AND
MICHAEL LANE FROM SPARK THANK
YOU AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE HAVE- MISTER LANE
ON THE LINE FOR MR CARPER
PLEASE. FINDER OPEN. MANAGE
YOUR NUMBERS MICHAEL IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION A
PUBLIC POLICY THINK TANK KNOWN
AS BURKE IT IS TOO EXPENSIVE TO
BUILD HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA A
SINGLE UNIT A RENTAL HOUSE IN
OUR COASTAL AREAS CAN COST
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR MORE. WE DESPERATELY NEED
INNOVATION AND NEW APPROACHES.
WE MUST INCENTIVIZE BUILDING
TYPES CONSTRUCTION METHODS AND
FINANCING MODELS THEY CAN
REDUCE THE COST TO PROVIDE
GREATER AFFORDABILITY. WITH NO
ARE RELATIVELY SHOULD SHALLOW
PUBLIC SBSIDIES. VERY OFTEN
ACQUISITION REHABILITATION OF
EXISTING BUILDINGS CAN COST
LESS THAN HALF OF NEW
CONSTRUCTION. THE RENT AND THEN
WE CAPS AND THE PROPERTY
MANAGER OVER TIME TO CREATE
GREATER AFFORDABILITY. MANY
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE STATE
REPORT NO MODERATE INCOME UNITS
ON THEIR ANNUAL PROGRESS
REPORTS TO EXCEEDING. EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN WILL PROVIDE
A WAY TO ADDRESS THIS
DEFICIENCY AMERICAN IDOL. THANK
YOU. AND NOW WILL HAVE A MISTER
SCOTT HARPER. YEAH THANK YOU SO
HELLO HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HAVING ME MY NAME IS SCOTT
CARPER I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY HOUSING AGENCY OR
CALC AJ. CONTOURING AB SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BEFORE YOU TODAY.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS ISSUE. AT A TIME WHEN
CALIFORNIANS IT CONTINUED
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. RELATED TO
THE ONGOING COATED NINETEEN
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
UNSUSTAINABLE HOUSING COSTS AND
THE PERSISTENT THREAT OF
DISPLACEMENT WE NEED INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO DRIVE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY FOR ALL. COUNTY
HA WAS FORMS TO SQUARELY
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S GROWING
AFFORDABILITY AND THAT MIDDLE
INCOME HOUSING CRISIS. WE
UTILIZE REVENUES GENERATED FROM
THE SALE OF COUNTY AJ ISSUE
GOVERNMENTAL REVENUE BONDS TO
FULLY FINANCE THE ACQUISITION
AND CONVERSION OF EXISTING
MARKET RATE APARTMENT
COMMUNITIES TO RENT RESTRICTED
HOUSEHOLDS. BURNING BELOW 120%
AREA MEDIAN INCOME. THIS
EQUATES TO HOUSING FOR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS LIKE NURSES
TEACHERS FIRST RESPONDERS
LIBRARIANS AND SOCIAL WORKERS
EACH OF WHOM EARN TOO MUCH TO
QUALIFY FOR TRADITIONAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROGRAMS YET
INCREASINGLY NOT ENOUGH TO LIVE
WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE.THROUGH THAT PROCESS WE
BECAME AWARE THAT TODAY THERE
WAS NO MESSAGE FOR CITIES TO
CLAIM CREDIT FOR THESE TYPE OF
CONVERSION. BUT EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD PROVIDE
CITIES WITH A MODEST PATHWAY TO
RECEIVING CREDIT IN THEIR
ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORTS FOR THE
CONVERSION OF MARKET RATE
UNITS. TO DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE UNITS. BUT
INCENTIVIZING THE LONG TERM
PRESERVATION OF LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING WHILE
GUARANTEEING LONG TERM
AFFORDABILITY AND RENTER
PROTECTION. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME CONSIDERATION AND
THANK YOU AGAIN TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL AND HIS TEAM FOR
YOUR CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU OPERATORS OR ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL ONLINE. Q. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE ABOUT FOUR INCH YOU WILL
GO TO LINE THREE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN BROKEN
COALITION FOR SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOODS SPEAKING ON MY
OWN BEHALF. IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
FIVE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUSTIN HIGHER
POLITICAL COMBAT READERSHIP
GROUP PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN FIVE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE THE REYNOLDS FROM
CALIFORNIA ADVISORS ON BEHALF
OF THE LOW IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU I THREE FIFTEEN
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE OF
THOSE COULD BE WITH THE CEMENT
MASONS LOCAL FOUR HUNDRED. AND
WILL SUPPORT THE AB SEVEN
EXCEPT IT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I SEE
NONE IN THE GALLERY. IN THE ON
THE PHONE LINE PLEASE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN EIGHT
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO OF
WANTING CURETIS THE ONE MOMENT
FOR THAT LINE.
FOUR SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR SIX FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE
FROM. HER LIKE COMMOTION
POSSIBLY HERE TO REALLY DO IT.
DID WE ARE DOING IT. YEAH RIVAS.
SECRETARY DO YOU KNOW HOW THE
MOTION- BOERNER HORVATH AND
VOEPEL OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
OKAY- WOULD YOU LIKE TO- CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTED A
MANAGER CREATE WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS BILL- IT
GIVES LOCAL AGENCIES ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY TO CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THROUGH UNIT
CONVERSIONS. I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY MOTIONS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. HUSS
YOU DETECTED MINUTES CLASS
RELICS THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
HAI LACKEY. HELLO FOR HARDWARE
HI BOERNER HORVATH I RONALD
RONALD I WAS REDUCED FROM HIS
ASIDE ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS
I WILL TELL. I WILL TELL HI YOU
HAVE. SIX ZERO SIX ZERO. ALL
RIGHT ONE MOMENT HERE NEXT BILL
THAT WOULD BE ITEM FOR. AB NINE
EIGHTY NINE PROCEEDS WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH AROUND HERE- PLEASED
TO PRESENT THIS BILL AS WELL
WHICH WOULD CREATE A
SPECIALIZED APPEAL PANEL TO
ADDRESS SITUATIONS WHERE LOCAL
OFFICIALS SEEK TO PREVENT THE
DEVELOPMENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN VIOLATION OF STATE LAW. THE
LEGISLATION IS A MODEST EFFORT
TO STRENGTHEN THE PURPOSE AND
INTENT OF THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. AUSTIN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO THIS ACT
AIMS TO PREVENT EFFORTS TO
BLOCK THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THAT
OTHERWISE COMPLIES WITH THE
APPLICABLE GENERAL PLAN AND
ZONING AND SUBDIVISION
STANDARDS. UNFORTUNATELY
DESPITE CALIFORNIA WELL
DOCUMENTED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS. SOME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE DEFIED THE ACT AND TONIGHT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
EVEN WHEN THEY ARE FULLY
COMPLIANT WITH ALL LOCAL ZONING
AND REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS.
THESE OFFICIALS UNDERSTAND THAT
IN MOST CASES AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROPONENTS WILL HAVE NO
PRACTICAL MEANS TO CHALLENGE
THE UNLAWFUL DENIAL. AS THE
CURRENT REMEDY LITIGATION IN
SUPERIOR COURT. IS ALMOST
ALWAYS PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE
TIME CONSUMING AND OTHERWISE
IMPRACTICAL. AB NINE EIGHT NINE
WOULD ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM BY
CREATING AN ALTERNATE REVIEW
PANEL WITH SPECIALIZED
EXPERTISE. MODELED AFTER AN
APPROACH THAT HAS SUCCESSFULLY
BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN OTHER
STATES. THE REVIEW PANEL WHEN
IT COULD REPRESENTATIVES FROM
BOTH LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IMPORTANTLY
THE JURISDICTION OF THE REVIEW
PANEL WOULD BE VERY NARROW AND
LIMITED TO ONLY ONE ISSUE.
WHETHER THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
VIOLATED THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT BY
DISAPPROVING A PROJECT WITHOUT
MAKING THE APPROPRIATE FINDINGS
AS REQUIRED BY LAW. THE PANEL
WITH US WE WERE ABLE TO RESOLVE
THIS DISPUTE. ANYMORE EXPEDITED
IT LESS EXPENSIVE LESS
CONFRONTATIONAL AND MORE
CONSISTENT MANNER. TO BE CLEAR
AB NINE EIGHT NINE SIMPLY
PROVIDES A NEW PROCEDURAL
REMEDY TO RESOLVE DISPUTES IT
DOES NOT HAPPEN DON'T CHANGE
ANY LOCAL ZONING OR LAND USE
POLICIES OR OTHERWISE CHANGE
SOMETHING OF STATE LAW AROUND
HOUSING. LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THE FALL STATE LAW ON GOOD
FAITH ARE HIGHLY UNLIKELY TO
HAVE ANY INTERACTION WITH THIS
REVIEW PANEL. THIS LESS
ADVERSARIAL AND MORE COST
EFFECTIVE APPROACH IS SUPPORTED
BY A BROAD COALITION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GROUPS
HOUSING ADVOCATES AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY ARE TWENTY BELIEVE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND MARK STIVERS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP THANK YOU RECOVERY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
BELIEVE REMARKS MARK STIVERS
HERE IN THE GALLERY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SPEAK FIRST. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS- MARC DIVERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP. THE PARTNERSHIP
PROVIDES TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO MOST OF THE NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
IN THE STATE. OUR PARTNERS ARE
WELL AWARE THAT A GOOD NUMBER
OF COMMUNITIES ARE NOT ARE
UNWELCOMING OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. WE HEAR OFTEN FROM OUR
DEVELOPERS THEY THEY WILL NOT
TAKE THE FINANCIAL RISK TO BUY
A PROPERTY IF THEY DON'T THINK
THEY CAN GET THROUGH THE LOCAL
ENTITLEMENT PROCESS. WELL THE
EXISTING HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT IN THEORY PROTECTS
DEVELOPERS FROM ARBITRATE
DENIALS OR UNREASONABLE
CONDITIONS. TO MAKE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF FEASIBLE IS A
RELATIVELY EMPTY PROTECTION.
VERY FEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS WILL SPEND HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
LEGAL FEES INTEREST AND
ADDITIONAL CARRYING COSTS. AT
LEAST TWO YEARS OF THEIR TIME
TO GO THROUGH THE COURTS. THE
ADMINISTRATIVE APPEALS BODY
CONCEPT HAS BEEN TRIED AND
FOUND SUCCESSFUL IN
MASSACHUSETTS WHERE IT'S BEEN
IN PLACE SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
ONE. AND ALSO RHODE ISLAND
ILLINOIS AND OREGON. RT HEALTH
AB NINE NINE WILL SIT. CHANGE
THE RISK PROFILE GIVING THEM
GREATER CERTAINTY AND
CONFIDENCE TO BRING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROPOSALS FORWARD AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY GET THEM
BUILT. AB NINETY NINE IS ABOUT
EFFICIENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR STIVERS- NOW WITH
TWENTY BROUGH IT MOVIES ON THE
PHONE I BELIEVE OPERATOR. YES
THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBERS. TWENTY
TO CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION I'LL BE BRIEF STINT
A LOT OF. GOOD POINTS ALREADY
MADE- BUT ABOUT THE BILL. AS
PREVIOUSLY STATED AB NINE EIGHT
NINE DOES NOT TAKE. AWAY LOCAL
CONTROL BUT THE BILL SIMPLY
ALLOWS ME TO CREATE A STATE
APPEALS. PANEL TO REVIEW IN
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT PROJECT
ISSUE THE REJECTION WAS DONE
ACCORDING TO CURRENT STATE LAW.
WHILE THE HOUSE IN CALGARY
ACTIVE STRONG LAW GOVERNMENT
WILL PLAN USED TO DESIGN A POOR
BUT HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS. MOST
DEVELOPERS ARE HAVING TO GO TO
COURT- DUE TO THE TIME AND
MONEY SOCIAL OCCASION AS
PRETTY. AS WELL. AGAIN THIS
BILL IS A PERSONABLE- IMPORTANT
TOOL TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH
CURRENT STATE HELPING WALLS- IN
THE BOOKS TODAY- AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR.
YOUR AYE BUT WHEN THE TIME
COMES THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SABRINA WE NOW ARE
LOOKING FOR OTHER WITNESSES. IN
SUPPORT OPERATOR. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
EIGHT IT NOW EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO I THIS
TIME. OKAY I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT SIXTEEN Q. WILL
BORDERLINE FIVE FIVE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHEN MEMBERS MY NAME IS ANGEL
GROANED WITH THE SACRAMENTO
HOUSING ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT OF
THE EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT FIVE SIX FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MA'AM CARE
MEMBERS ACROSS BUCKLEY ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO MAYOR
DARRELL STAMMERED IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FIVE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GLAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KIDNEY FAN ON BEHALF
OF BRIDGE HOUSING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I FIVE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KIMBERLY DONE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M FIVE
SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
SIX EIGHT. I HAVE NO FURTHER
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. MEMBERS NONE IN THE
GALLERY. I WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE
MANAGER THIS IS JASON RANG WE
CALIFORNIA CITY. WELCOME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL- AGAIN
WE CALIFORNIA CITIES MUST
OPPOSE EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY NINE
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
CONSIDERING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE IN THE ANALYSIS I HAVEN'T
HEARD YET WHETHER THE THERE'S
GONNA TAKE THOSE MOMENTS BUT
THOSE MOMENTS CERTAINLY-
IMPROVE THE BILL AND DO ADDRESS
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS HOWEVER A
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE REMAINS- WE
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT IT'S A
APPROPRIATE TO ALLOW A BODY
THAT'S MADE UP OF GOVERNOR
POINT SHE'S TO SECOND GUESS A
LAWFUL HOUSING PROJECT DENIAL
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT DETERMINATION IS BEST
LEFT TO THE COURTS ONE OF THE
PRIMARY FUNCTIONS OF OUR
JUDICIARY ATTENTION WE ARBITER
OF THOSE CASES AND WE FEEL
STRONGLY THAT NEEDS TO REMAIN
THERE I'M THE ANALYSIS TO
REALLY- APPROPRIATELY AND
ACCURATELY OUTLINED SOME OF THE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED IN RECENT YEARS TO THE
OTHER ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AND
ALSO THE CREATION OF HDDS
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY YET FROM
THESE CHANGES ARE SIGNIFICANT
AND- I STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT
OUR CITIES ARE ARE NOT YOU
KNOW- ARBITRARILY OR
INTENTIONALLY. IDENTIFIED HOW
WE CAN ABILITY ACT IF THEY DO
SO THEY WILL FACE A TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR PER UNITS
FINANCED FOR NOT FOLLOWING THAT
ACT- SO AGAIN I THINK I THINK
THAT OUR CITIES ARE CERTAINLY-
NOT GONNA GET A VIOLATE THAT
LAW IN A LOT OF WAYS I'M AB
NINETY NINE ISN'T NECESSARY- WE
BELIEVE IT'LL LEAD TO
ADDITIONAL DELAYS AND
UNCERTAINTY- SOME TO GET THERE
THIS APPEALS BODY IF THEY DO
NOT RULE IN FAVOR OF THE CITY
I'M SURE THAT OUR CITIES WILL
WILL CHALLENGE THAT IN COURT AS
WELL SO- ULTIMATELY WILL END UP
IN THE SAME PLACE- YOU KNOW WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S DESIRE
TO STREAMLINE HOUSING TO MAKE
IT QUICKER FASTER CHEAPER
BETTER. THAT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT WE CALIFORNIA
CITY STRONGLY SUPPORTS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT ACCOUNTABILITY
WILL NEVER DEFEND ANYWHERE
CITIES THAT VIOLATE THE LAW
WILL COOLEY- BUT UNFORTUNATELY
EIGHTEEN NINETY NINE IS NOT THE
ANSWER AND WE HAVE TO OPPOSE
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DO YOU HAVE ANY.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU HAVE TO I THINK
YOU THREE NINE THREE CALL.
THANK YOU. I MEAN BROKEN
KOHLI'S FOR SO FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOOD. SPEAKING- ON MY
OWN BEHALF. AN OFFICER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FIVE SIX
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRISTOPHER LEE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ALSO
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER WINDING QUEUE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH-
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
COME FROM ONE OF THE CITIES
WHERE I'M NOT SURE I AGREE WITH
YOUR YOUR WITNESS THAT-
DEVELOPERS DON'T HAVE MONEY SO
IF THEY LIKE THIS WAS A LOT-
BUT IS NOT FOR VIOLATING THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT- BUT
I DO BELIEVE THERE'S A VALUE.
IN CREATING ANYTHING THAT
ENCOURAGES MEDIATION AND KEEP
CITIES OUT OF COURT I'VE SAID
THIS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE ALL
KNOWS. MY CITY HAS SPENT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TRYING TO
GET IT RIGHT- AND SO I THINK
THERE'S A VALUE IN CREATING
THIS BODY I'M VERY HAPPY WITH
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. OF
TWO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REPRESENTATIVES- ON THIS
APPEALS FOR BUT I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS SO FIRST OF ALL DO WE
KNOW HOW MANY CITIES HAVE BEEN
ACCUSED AND- TAKEN TO COURT FOR
VIOLATING HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. LAST YEAR
TOO YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW THE
EXACT NUMBER I THINK WHAT WHAT
THIS BILL IS GETTING OUT IS
NINE THOSE INSTANCES WHERE EACH
CD GETS INVOLVED BUT THOSE
INSTANCES WHERE CITIES GET
INVOLVED IN WHAT WE'VE HEARD IS
OUR WITNESS TESTIFIED FROM THE
INDUSTRY IS THAT THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE. DON'T WANT TO LITIGATE
BECAUSEIT'S GOING TO TAKE TWO
OR THREE YEARS OR PICKING A
JUDGE OUT OF THE HOT SUPERIOR
COURT WHO MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE
ANY IDEA WHAT THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT SAYS IT'S
GOING TO BE VERY EXPENSIVE.
YOU'RE LIKELY TO GET INTO
KALYTERA COLLATERAL ISSUES OF
THE SCOPE OF DISCOVERY AND SO
IT'S ACTUALLY JUST DISCOURAGING
PEOPLE FROM FROM DEVELOPING IN
THE FIRST PLACE SO WE FEEL LIKE
THERE'S A STRONG RATIONALE FOR
THE BILL BASED ON WHAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND. OKAY AND- ONE OF THE
THINGS AND I AND I THINK WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS. BUT THE FACT
THAT ONLY THE DEVELOPER CAN
APPEAL THE DECISION. MAKES
THIS. GIVES THE APPEARANCE THE
DEVELOPER HAS THE POWER. AND I
DON'T THINK- A CITY WOULD SAY
AREN'T OUR DECISION WAS WRONG
BUT IF THEY GET A THREAT OF
LITIGATION THIS MIGHT BE A
GREAT WAY TO MEDIATE SO I'D
LIKE TO ASK YOU TO LOOK AT THAT
EXPLORE PERHAPS. AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD- COULD THERE BE
SOMETHING WHERE IT'S FAIR AND
I'M MORE FOCUSED ON MEDIATION
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S WHERE
THE REAL VALUE IN THIS BILL.
COMES FROM- AND- COULD YOU WALK
US THROUGH BECAUSE I THINK. I
DON'T NECESSARILY UNDERSTAND
PERFECTLY. HOW DOES THIS
APPEALS BOARD WORK. RELATED TO
THE CITY'S OWN DECISION MAKING
PROCESS. THE COASTAL COMMISSION
BECAUSE MOST OF THEM A LARGE
PART OF MY DISTRICT HAS THE
COASTAL COMMISSION. AND THEN
HOW DOES IT WORK IN CIVIL
COURTS IF YOU CAN LOOK AT THAT
INTERSECTION. AND KIND OF WALK
US THROUGH IT AND I THINK THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. FOR SOME
FOLKS IN THE OPPOSITION AS WELL
HERE YEAH ABSOLUTELY AND I AND
I WILL SAY. I SHOULD SAY THIS
FIRST OFF JUST TO WE WILL
ACTUALLY BE ACCEPTING
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND I
THINK THEY'RE VERY HELPFUL I
WANT TO THANK. THE CHAIR AND
HER STAFF FOR THOSE AMENDMENTS
AND- AS I READ IT IT ADDRESSES-
ALL OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE LEAGUE EXCEPT FOR ONE-
WHERE I THINK WE HAVE A
RESPECTFUL DISAGREEMENT. V. THE
WAY THAT THIS WOULD WORK- SORT
OF IN IN THEORY IS- ADD A
DEVELOPER WOULD COME FORWARD
SUBMIT. A PROPOSAL TO BUILD
SOME AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THAT
WOULD BE FULLY COMPLIANT WITH
THE ZONING. THAT WAS DECIDED BY
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT THEY SAID
THIS IS THIS IS MERRY IN THE
CITY WHERE YOU CAN BUILD THIS
TYPE OF HOUSING. YOU KNOW
THERE'S AN ARBITRARY AND
UNLAWFUL DENIAL THE CITY
DOESN'T MAKE THE REQUIRED
FINDINGS AS AS REQUIRED UNDER
THE HOUSING COMPANY ACT. THE
DEVELOPER COULD THEN DECIDE
THAT THEY WANTED TO APPEAL THAT
DECISION TO THIS SPECIALIZED
REVIEW BOARD. THEY WOULD HAVE
THE BURDEN BY A PREPONDERANCE
OF EVIDENCE TO DEMONSTRATE. ON
THAT VERY VERY NARROW ISSUE
THIS THIS IS NOT MEANT TO GET
INTO A LOT OF DIFFERENT KINDS
ISSUES IN A VERY NARROW ISSUE.
WITH PEOPLE WITH SPECIALIZED
EXPERTISE THE CITY DID NOT MAKE
THE REQUIRED FINDINGS. IF THEY
COULD DEMONSTRATE THAT. THE
CITY WOULD THEN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REBUT THAT TO
SHOW WHY DID THAT THEY DID IN
FACT HAVE. THE APPROPRIATE
FINDINGS TO MAKE THAT DECISION
TO DENY IT- AND THEN IT WOULD
BE UP TO THIS- THIS PANEL TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION. WHAT WE
FOUND FROM FROM- FROM
MASSACHUSETTS AND OTHER STATES
IS THAT THE DECISIONS TEND TO
BE NEXT IT IS NOT MEANT TO BE
A- A BODY THAT COMES DOWN ON
ONE SIDE OR THE OTHER AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES BOTH FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FROM JURISDICTIONS
LARGER JURISDICTIONS SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS. AND FROM FOLKS
WITH SPECIALIZED EXPERTISE. I
DELETE TO YOUR POINT- THE
PARTIES WOULD ACTUALLY SETTLE
BEFORE THAT HAPPENED- AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
ATTRACTED TO ME ABOUT THIS BILL
IS. I THINK IT WAS AND I DON'T
KNOW MAYBE MISS REMEMBER
EXACTLY WHAT I THINK WAS 71% OF
THE APPEALS ACTUALLY SETTLED
BEFORE THEY WERE HURT- SO THIS
ACTUALLY INDUCED TO THE PARTIES
TO COME TO SOME AGREEMENT. TO
NEGOTIATE A COMPROMISE AVOIDING
THE EXPENSE AND DELAY. AND
CONTROVERSY OF LITIGATION. IF
YOU DID HAVE A DECISION FROM AN
APPEAL PANEL THAT EITHER PARTY
DON'T LIKE. EITHER PARTY COULD
THEN. APPEAL THAT DECISION TO-
TO IT TOO TO THE SUPERIOR COURT
SO IT DOESN'T TAKE AWAY
ANYBODY'S OPPORTUNITY TO AT THE
END OF THE DAY. SEEK A JUDICIAL
DETERMINATION IN COURT BUT WHAT
IT WHAT WE HOPE IT WILL DO. IS
PROVIDE AN INCENTIVE FOR PEOPLE
TO NEGOTIATE COMPROMISE AND GET
THINGS DONE ON THE FRONT DESK.
AND THAT ABILITY TO COMPROMISE
ONE OF THE REASONS I LIKE TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS
BECAUSE I THINK. YOU'RE ON TO
SOMETHING HERE- BUT I YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT ABILITY TO
COMPROMISE AND MEDIATE IS WHERE
THE REAL POWER IN THIS BILL IS-
DO YOU KNOW HOW IT WORKS. WITH
THE IN THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. USUALLY ANY LAND
USE DECISION WE MAKE IN THE
COASTAL ZONE- CAN BE APPEALED
ON ITS FACE TO. THE COASTAL
COMMISSION SO WHERE WOULD. THIS
FIT IN TO THAT. PROCESS YOU
KNOW THAT'S IT'S AN ACTUAL
QUESTION I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE
I'M HAPPY TO GET THAT ANSWER
FOR YOU AND I YOU KNOW VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
FEEDBACK YOU'VE GIVEN HONEST ON
HAPPY TO CAN. TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT I WILL HAVE
TO GET BACK ON THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. AND I APPRECIATE
YOU ALSO. AS HAVING THIS
DIALOGUE AND YOU KNOW I KNOW
YOU'RE CONTINUING TO WORK ON
IT. AND WITH THAT I'LL GIVE A
COURTESY I TODAY AND HOPE TO
SEE. THE CONTINUED. IMPROVEMENT
IN THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK VERY MUCH OF THEIR
IN OTHER. OF THE COMMITTEE- TO
RE HAVING MOTION WE NEED A
MOTION PLANES WILL GO. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS OKAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK HERE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU- THANK YOU WAS
WORKING WITH MY COMMITTEE ON
THE AMENDMENTS ON THIS BILL THE
BILL CREATES AN EXPEDIA A
PROCESS TO RESOLVE VIOLATIONS
OF HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
THAT MAY LACK THE RESOURCES TO
PURSUE REMEDIES IN COURT. I
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT
ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE COMPLY
WITH THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT. THIS WILL HELP
INSURE THAT ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED IN HEARINGS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE ARE AFFORDED STANDARD
LEVELS OF DUE PROCESS. THAT
APPLY TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE
APPEALS ULTIMATELY THIS WILL
STRENGTHEN THE COMMITTEE ENSURE
THAT ITS ACTIONS ARE
TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABLE I
AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY. AND THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI. I LUCKY. BLOOM
I WILL I BOERNER HORVATH. THE
HARD RIGHT AND- BOB ALL RIGHT
THREE OF US HI RIVAS I
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
VOEPEL HI WILL TELL HI YOU HAVE.
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WELL I'VE NEVER SEEN
PREVIOUSLY. YEARS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING
AB EIGHT OH THREE AB EIGHT OH
THREE THE STARTER HOME
REVITALIZATION AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
DEVELOPMENT PROMOTED STATEWIDE
TO SUBMIT APPLICATIONS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION A FEW SIMPLE
INFILL HOUSING ON SMALL LOTS-
IN MULTI FAMILY AND MIXED USE
ZONES. TO ATTRACT NEW RESIDENTS
CITIES MUST PROVIDE NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS AS
THE CASE STUDY FOR THE LOS
ANGELES SMALLER OR NICHE SHOWS
SMALL HOME NOT DEVELOPMENTS ARE
FEE SIMPLE UNITS THAT INCREASE
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
WHILE WORKING WITH EXISTING
LAND USE DESIGNATIONS. ALTHOUGH
THESE DEVELOPMENTS DO NOT
INCREASE IS OWNING DENSITY
pUTILIZED LOTS OF THIS INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF UNITS MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC. WE
NEED ALL THE TOOLS IN OUR
TOOLBOX IN ORDER TO ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS. AB ZERO THREE
IS A VERY SMALL SHIFT IT WAYS
THE MINIMUM LOT SIZES AS LONG
AS YOU BOTH THE DENSITY. TO DO
FEES SIMPLE ZERO LOT LINE HOMES
IS THE PRECONDITION FOR TINY
HOMES. IT'S THE PRECONDITION
FOR ROW HOMES AND WHAT YOU
DON'T WAIVE PARKING MINIMUMS
BUT WE SAY. A CITY CANNOT
REQUIRE AN H. AWAY AND IT
CANNOT REQUIRE HOMES FOR CARS
SO IT DOES DO SOME THINGS THAT
MAKE IT FEASIBLE. AND REALLY
COULD SET THAT MISSING MIDDLE
HOUSING THAT WE NEED IN
CALIFORNIA TO REALLY HELP
PEOPLE BE ABLE TO BUY AND BUILD
EQUITY. IN THE HOUSING MARKET
WELL I'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT WE
HAVE TAKEN AMENDMENTS IN
HOUSING. SO WE HAVE REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AS ON
THOUGH BECAUSE I THINK SOME OF
YOU KNOW THIS IS MY THIRD YEAR
RUNNING THIS BILL- THAT THREE
TIMES THE TERM HOPEFULLY- BUT I
WROTE THIS BILL WITH A FRIEND
OF MINE MY- OF MY FRIEND
ARCHITECT AN ARCHITECT. BRETT
FERRE WHO I HOPE IS ON THE LINE
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WERE COMING
UP RIGHT OW- SO HE'S HERE TO
ANSWER I DON'T I KNOW WE-
BILLS. WELL THAT'S BET DOES SO
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE BILL WHY IT'S NEEDED. YOU
KNOW WE'VE DONE A LOT OF THINGS
TO LIMITED SO THAT IS REALLY
GOING TO INCREASE COMMUNITY
CHARACTER PROVIDE TRANSITIONS
FROM SINGLE FAMILY TO MULTI
FAMILY. AND INCREASE
HOMEOWNERSHIP SO IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS BRETT'S HERE TO
ANSWER BUT THEN I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER TAKE
A DEEP BREATH. THEY CAN. MAKE
OF. OKAY DO HAVE A WE HAVE A WE
TO IT IS I BELIEVE IN PART
BRADFORD FIVE ARCHITECT AND
THEN BRIAN GROVER MAYBE I THINK
ONLY PRESS ON THE PHONE AND I
THINK BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
MEETING SO LONG HE'S HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY SO
WE'LL MAKE THAT EASIER THAN WE
THOUGHT. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OPERATOR
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT OH THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE NONE IN THE GALLERY HE
WISHES. PLEASE PROCEED IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB EIGHT OH THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE. I DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THIS SHIP. THE MOVE
OKAY WE HAVE MISSED A SUMMER
VOEPEL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS- WE'RE TRYING TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE- THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND I KNOW THIS BILL
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
QUITE SOME TIME AND I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE BEING
CREATIVE TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO
DEVELOP MORE HOUSING THAT WORKS
IN YOUR DISTRICT AND ACROSS THE
STATE. I'M PLEASED TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY OUR MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY NIGHT AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE LACKEY BLOOM. HELLO I'M
BOERNER HORVATH HI. I RAMOS.
THREE OF US THREE OF US SIDE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS HOTEL
ITSELF ARE YOU HAVE.
SIX ZERO.
OKAY SO- I BELIEVE THIS IS THE
LAST ITEM ON THE AGENDA IT
WOULD BE A FILE ITEM. NINETEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
CHAIRWOMAN SOME GOOD AFTERNOON
THE CHAIRMAN AND VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS. MEMBERS ONE IN EIGHT
CALIFORNIA HOME STILL DO NOT
HAVE INTERNET ACCESS IN IN
SMALL TOWNS RURAL AREAS THAT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FACE EVEN
HIGHER NUMBERS OF STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES WHO REMAIN
DISCONNECTED UNDER THE CURRENT
STANDARDS AND THE SEC IS
CONSIDERING ACTION TO
SIGNIFICANTLY RAISE THOSE
STANDARDS AS WE SPEAK. RECENT
EVENTS HAVE MADE GLARINGLY
CLEAR HOW CRITICAL CONNECTIVITY
IN THAT IS IN TIMES OF
EMERGENCIES. INCLUDING THE
MASSIVE TRANSITION OF STUDENTS
LEARNING FROM HOME. ACCESS BY
SMALL BUSINESSES TO THE DIGITAL
ECONOMY TELEHEALTH WIND
HEALTHAXIS IS CONSTRAINED.
STATING FOR WILDFIRES THAT IS
WHY I'M PARTNERING WITH SENATOR
GONZALEZ AND TWO DOZEN OF OUR
COLLEAGUES. OVER THE PAST
MONTHS WE'VE WORKED TOGETHER ON
A LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE THAT WILL
MODERNIZE STANDARDS AND UPDATE
THEM AS THE FCC STANDARDS
EVOLVED TO ADOPT NEW SPEEDS AND
TECHNOLOGY. OUR BILLS WILL
PROVIDE ELIGIBILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUNDING AT TWENTY FIVE DOWNLOAD
THREE UPLOAD WITH A BILL THAT
AT TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE. AB
FOURTEEN PRIORITIZES THE
DEPLOYMENT OF BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE. UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED RURAL AND URBAN
AREAS WHILE OPENING THE DOOR
FOR A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS TO PROVIDE
CONNECTIVITY IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE PRIVATE
SECTOR CANNOT OR CHOOSES NOT TO
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT SERVICE. AB
FOURTEEN PROVIDES FOR AN
EXTENSION OF THE SURCHARGE ON
THE TELECOM SERVICE AND BONDING
FOR YEARS WHEN THE APPLICATIONS
EXCEED THE INCOMING REVENUE THE
BILL PROJECTS NOW. WELL WE WORK
WITH LEADERSHIP AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE EXACT
METHOD FOR EXTENDING THE
WIRELINE CUSTOMERS WILL
ACTUALLY BE WILL ACTUALLY
DECREASE IN THE NEW PROGRAM. MY
BILL ENSURES GRANTS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CPUC
COMMISSIONERS ARE AWARDED TO
APPLICANTS WHO ARE WILLING. AND
ABLE TO QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY
CONNECT HOUSEHOLDS COMMUNITY
ANCHOR INSTITUTIONS SMALL
BUSINESSES AND EMPLOYERS BY
MAKING ELIGIBLE ANCHOR
INSTITUTIONS ALONG THE PATHWAY
OF A PROJECT SO THAT WE DO NOT
MISS OPPORTUNITIES TO BROAD
LINKAGES. TO HEALTH EDUCATION
PUBLIC SAFETY AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE RESEARCH FACILITIES.
WE HAVE ALSO HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
CREATE THOUSANDS OF JOBS FOR
MORE CALIFORNIA WORKERS WHO
WILL NEED TO HAVE THE SKILLS
AND TRAINING TO DELIVER THESE
PROJECTS. AND AS WE WORK WITH
MISTER SPEAKER AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE FINAL
PACKAGE I'M EXCITED TO CONTINUE
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES A
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS. FOR
SURE CALIFORNIA WORKERS BENEFIT
FROM THESE HIGH PAYING CAREERS
IN TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE. A
GREAT MANY OF US ARE WORKING ON
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF THIS FIGHT
TOGETHER WE'VE BUILT THE
MOMENTUM TO SUCCEED THIS YEAR.
NOW IS THE TIME TO SEIZE THE
MOMENT AND BRING ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST SIX CENTURY FOR THEIR
WORK HEALTH AND QUALITY OF
LIFE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE IN WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS TRISH KELLY ON
BEHALF OF VALLEY VISION AND
EDUARDO GONZALEZ. I'M BEHALF
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY REGIONAL
BROADBAND CONSORTIUM AND FRESNO
STATE THANK YOU. K. OPERATOR
COULD WE- LIST EITHER EDUARDO
OR TRASH. CUEBALL FINDS THEIR
OPEN. NOW GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS TRISH KELLY COMPELLING
VISION MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR DEDICATED
LEADERSHIP TO CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE OVER THE YEARS
INCLUDING CRITICALLY NEEDED
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
OUR CAPITAL REGION AND
STATEWIDE ALSO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COLLABORATION WITH SENATOR
GONZALEZ AND THE MANY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS TO CONNECT OUR UNSERVED
AND UNDERSERVED HOUSEHOLDS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. URGENCY
LEGISLATION WITH AT FOURTEEN.
WELL YOUR VISION MA'AM THE
CONNECTED CAPITAL AREA
BROADBAND CONSORTIUM WHICH IS
ONE OF THE TWELVE CONSORTIUM
FUNDED BY THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND. AND THEY WORK
THROUGH THIS WORK WE WORK WITH
PROVIDERS TO CONNECT THE 98% OF
OUR HOUSEHOLDS IN THE REGION BY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. YOUR
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THE REGION HAS UP MORE
THAN THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
UNSERVED HOUSEHOLDS AT THIS
MOMENT AS DEFINED BY THE BEAUTY
AND WE KNOW THE NUMBER IS
HIGHER WHEN WE CONDUCT SPEED
TESTING AND VALIDATE ACTUAL
VERSUS REPORTED LEVELS OF SPEED
AND SERVICE. WE ALSO MENTION
MANAGE THAT SACRAMENTO
COALITION FOR DIGITAL INCLUSION
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO THE LIBRARY THE
STATE SECTOR ST LOS RIOS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT ARE
WORKFORCE BOARDS AND PVO. THIS
WORK IS FOCUSED ON BROADBAND
ACCESS AND ADOPTION. AFFORDABLE
SERVICES AND DEVICES. AND
DIGITAL AND- SO WE SEE ALL
ASPECTS OF THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
WHICH IS HUGE. AT THE CURRENT
RATE OF COLLECTIONS FOR THE P.
YOU FEED CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND WHICH FUNDED
BENEFITS STRUCTURE IT WOULD
TAKE A HUNDRED YEARS FOR US TO
MEET THE 98% GOAL ACROSS THE
STATE. ESTIMATED RIGHT NOW BY
THE P. SEE A CLOSE TO SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS. THE GAPS IN
OUR REGION IS HUGE IT WOULD
COST A MINIMUM OF ALMOST FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR US
TO CONNECT OUR UNSERVED
HELPFUL. NOT TO MENTION THE
THOUSANDS OF UNDERSERVED
HELPFUL IN- ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED URBAN
NEIGHBORHOODS. THE FUND IS ALSO
OR WITH DESCRIBES DEMONSTRATING
THE HIGH DEMAND.FOR THIS THE
FUNDING RESOURCE. THEREFORE WE
CANNOT REACH OUR BUDGETS.
MANDATED 8% TARGET WITHOUT
CONTINUED CAPTIVE FUNDING.
WHICH WILL TAKE SEVERAL YEARS
BEYOND TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE
SUPPORTED THE FOURTEEN BECAUSE
IT WILL PROVIDE FOR CONTINUED
INVESTMENT IN HIGH NEED
INFRASTRUCTURE IN BOTH URBAN
AND RURAL AREAS EXPAND FUNDING
ELIGIBILITY INCLUDING FOR LOCAL
AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS. AND
THIS WILL ENABLE NEW SOLUTIONS
WHERE THE PRIVATE SECTOR IS NOT
INVESTING WILL ALSO AS
MENTIONED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AG
WE ARE CURRY CONNECT ANCHOR
INSTITUTIONS ALONG THE PATH OF
DEPLOYMENT. AND IT WILL IMPROVE
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
PROGRAM SO PROJECTS ARE
COMPLETED SOONER. I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT THE P. YOU SEE
COST MODEL DOES NOT INCLUDE
ESTIMATES TO CONNECT
UNDERSERVED HOUSEHOLDS. AND
THIS IS A GREAT NEED TO WHICH
WE SEEM TO THE PANDEMIC
ESPECIALLY FOR HELP OPEN
STUDENTS STRUGGLING TO CONNECT
FOR DISTANCE LEARNING WE WILL
WORK TELL HEALTH AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND SO MUCH MORE. WE
KNOW IN OUR REGION WE'VE LOST
THOUSANDS OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ALONE DUE TO
THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE INTERNET
DEVICES AND ACCESS TO
BROADBAND. WE'VE ALSO ESTIMATED
THE COST TO CONNECT OUR
UNSERVED BUSINESS LOCATIONS
THAT. ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. SO A LOT OF IN
THE IS. IT'S A HUGE GAP AND WE
NEED- ALL THE RESOURCES WE CAN
TO MEET THIS CRITICAL GOAL.
CHAPTER IS A REALLY TRULY
IMPORTANT RESOURCE FOR THE
REGION'S TO MEET OUR
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE. I NOTE
THAT THE LEGISLATION IS FOR AN
EXTENSION OF THE CURRENT
SURCHARGE IT'S AN EXTREMELY
SMALL AMOUNT ON YOUR PHONE
BILL. BASED ON YOUR BILL
RANGING BETWEEN APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY AND FORTY PERCENT.
TWENTY AND FORTY CENTS MONTHLY.
MY MONTHLY CHARGES ON MY PHONE
BILLS FOR ITEMS LIKE CALL
WAITING MESSAGING AND CALLER ID
ARE FAR FAR HARDER SO I WOULD
RATHER PUT MY MONEY. INTO
CONNECTING ALL OF OUR
RESIDENTS. SO WE HOPE THAT YOU
WILL- CONSIDER THAT AND SUPPORT
THIS BILL ARE WE HAVE A GREAT
DEAL OF MOMENTUM TO MEET THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE CHALLENGE. AND
HELP DRIVE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
THIS LEGISLATION IS SUPPORTED
BY AN EXTREMELY BROAD NETWORK
OF ORGANIZATIONS STATEWIDE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. YOUR
IPHONE AND THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME SAID A LOT OF THE ONCE ON
THIS REPRESENTING THE OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY FRESNO. WHICH
ADMINISTERS THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY REGIONAL BROADBAND
CONSTRUCTION. AS MENTIONED
BEFORE ONE IN EIGHT CALIFORNIA
HOME STILL DO NOT HAVE INTERNET
ACCESS. IN THE PAST SEVERAL
MONTHS OUR CONSORTIA WORKING
CLOSELY WITH LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS
AND PARTNERS HAVE IDENTIFIED
MORE THAN SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS. AND EIGHT COUNTY
REGION WITH LIMITED OR NO
ACCESS TO BROADBAND. THESE
HOUSEHOLDS OF BOTH URBAN. AND
RURAL LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS
MAKING THE BROADBAND DIGITAL
DIVIDE IN CALIFORNIA AN EQUITY
ISSUE. TODAY I'M HERE TO ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS TO SUPPORT AB
FOURTEEN AS A STRATEGIC
SOLUTION TO CONNECTING
STUDENTS. FAMILIES AND BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO REMAIN DISCONNECTED
UNDER CURRENT STANDARDS. IF
BROADBAND HAD A TIME I WOULD
SAY IT'S NOW. BUT HOW CAN WE
FIX CALIFORNIA'S BROADBAND
NEEDS WITH MINIMAL FUNDING
CONTINUES BEARS TO DEPLOYMENT
CREATED BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
ALL CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY LIVE DEMOGRAPHICS
ARE HOUSEHOLD INCOME MORE
ENTITLED TO THE SAME PRIVILEGES
THAT YOU AND I WALK. HAVE HOPE
GETTING ONLINE AND SECURING AN
ADEQUATE BROADBAND SPEED.
APPARENTLY THAT'S NOT WHAT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR BELIEVES. DOES
THIS IS WHERE AB FOURTEEN COMES
TO PLAY OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS WOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
CONNECTIVITY. AND THEY'RE ALL
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE PRIVATE
SECTOR CANNOT OR CHOOSES NOT TO
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT SERVICE. AB
FOURTEEN PROVIDES FOR AN
EXTENSION OF THE SURCHARGE ON
TELECOM SERVICE AND BODY FOR
YEARS. ADDITIONALLY AS
MENTIONED BEFORE AB FOURTEEN
INSURANCE GRANTS ADMINISTERED
BY THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION OUR WATER
TO APPLICANTS WHO ARE WILLING
AND ABLE. TO QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY CONNECT CONSULS
COMMUNITY ANCHOR INSTITUTIONS
SMALL BUSINESSES EMPLOYERS TO-
BY MAKING ELIGIBLE ANCHORS JUST
ALONG THE PATHWAY OF A PROJECT
SO CALIFORNIANS. DON'T MISS
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE
LINKAGES. TO HELP JOB TWENTY AT.
ACCESS PUBLIC SAFETY EMERGES
RESPONSE WAS. AND FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
RIGHT BOOK. OKAY THANK YOU-
OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
A WOODEN OF CALLERS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE. IF YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY IN
THE QUEUE. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIVE SEVEN TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHE MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
ERICA HOPPING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN FIVE FIVE TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS THE
INTERAMERICAN WITH NORTH THE
BILL SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE FOR EIGHT
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
PRESIDENT'S ON BEHALF OF TRIPLE
P. AMERICA AND- CHEN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I TRY
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR NEW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN FORCED THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THE TICKET THE ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
THREE EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KEN AND KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
YOU BACK NAPA TULARE BUTTE. THE
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND NEVADA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ON SUPPORT
THIS AFTERNOON THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
FIVE SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS JENNIFER LOVE IT
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COURT ACTION IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
FIVE SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DO YOU TERM MEMBERS
SERVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I FIVE
SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEGHAN
SUPER COMBI HALF OF THE WRITERS
GUILD OF AMERICA WEST IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M THREE FIFTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU ONE OF THOSE
OKAY WITH THE CEMENT MASONS
LOCAL FOUR HUNDRED AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I FIVE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIX
NINE FIVE EIGHT ZERO. NINE FIVE
FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
HILLARY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN FIVE SEVEN SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
CAROLINE KERN COUNTY ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M FIVE EIGHT TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
VANESSA GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NEXT FIVE EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DO TO REVERSE WHAT
THE WORLD CAUCUS OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
FIND FIVE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ONE LUKE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND WE
SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RICHARD MEMBERS GREG COOK
REPRESENTING GOLDEN STATE POWER
COOPERATIVE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT AND GOOD LEGISLATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
YOUR MEMBERS JONATHAN HOWARD ON
BEHALF OF EIGHT SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY
THURMOND INSTRUCTS A PART OF AB
FOURTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIVE FIVE FIVE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF TURN THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK WITH THE SUPPORT
OF COMMENDED POSITION LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE UP AND LOOKING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BUT STILL THE- SO
LIZA SHY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS A LITTLE IT BUT
WHAT GETS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE SUPPORT IF AMENDED AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YASSER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FIVE FIVE EIGHT
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CALL HOLLY CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF WEST SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU I DON'T HAVE ANY MISTER
VICE CHAIR. YES SIR GO AHEAD.
MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
DIALOGUE WITH THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES REPORTED OH
TWO. AND SUPPORT. K. ANYBODY IN
THE VIDEO CONFERENCING AROUND.
OKAY I DON'T HAVE ANY LISTED-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO-
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION. TO AB
FOURTEEN. IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FOURTEEN OF PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY AT FORTY TWO OH TO
THE WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION. VIDEOCON CONFERENCE
ROOM. OKAY. DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT QUESTIONS OPPOSITION
ANY OF THE ABOVE. OKAY WE HAVE
A MOTION A SECOND. GOT A QUIET
GROUP UP HERE SO WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND LET YOU TO CLOSE THEM. I
PROVIDE A SIMPLY ASK FOR I VOTE
FOR THE FOR ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO. STEP
UP TO THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
SECRETARY OF THE GARAGE FOR THE
ROLE. WACKY NOPE EVEN THOUGH
AGUIAR-CURRY HI. I BLOOM BLOOM
I'D BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH NOT VOTING
RAMOS WELL MOST HI THIS
RIVERSIDE THREE OF US SIDE
ROBERT RIVAS WILL TELL YOU TELL
NO VOTE IS CURRENTLY FOR TWO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
OR JUST MAKING A NOTE WHICH
READ. AT THE TIME THE MEASURE
VOTE. OKAY WE ARE OPENING UP
THE ROLE FOR MEMBERS IF THEY
COULD COME BACK. OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY IF THERE'S NO OBJECTION
FROM THE COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE
TO REOPEN THE ROLE ON THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO ADD ON. I AM
NUMBER ONE. AB TWO FIFTEEN CHIU
BOAT IS CURRENTLY SIX ECHO
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH NOT VOTING
THREE OF US THREE OF US I HAD
THE BILL CURRENTLY IS SEVEN
ZERO THANK YOU. THE BILL'S
ADVOCATES. FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT A. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
GRAYSON VOTE IS CURRENTLY SIX
OH SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL BOERNER HORVATH. BERMAN
ARBUTHNOT BRODY THREE OF US HI
THIS RIVERSIDE VOTE IS SEVEN
ZERO BILL IS UP SEVEN ZERO.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB TEN
SEVENTEEN CORK SILVA VOTERS
CURRENTLY FIVE OH SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. YEAH NICE
WORK. YES HI. SEVENTEEN YEAH
YEAH I KNOW WE'RE ON SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT- RIGHT WE JUMPED
I'M SORRY I WAS ON APHONE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB TEN SEVENTEEN
I'M SORRY GOT OUT OF LINE HERE.
TWELVE SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT RIGHT.
BOERNER HORVATH AB SEVENTY
EIGHT YES BOERNER HORVATH ALL
RIGHT RAMOS RIGHT WELL AS I
ROBERT RIVAS THE BILL IS
CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO SHOWS OUT.
THE WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE-
PLEASE UP THE ROLE FOR BILLS ON
CALL. SENATE CALENDAR THE BOARD
IS CURRENTLY SIX ZERO LACKEY I.
HI BURKE ORDER. I REMEMBER
GREAT HARD LOTUS EIGHT ZERO ONE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. STRUCTURE.
PRINTED.
SINCE OUR- CONSENT
CALENDARS OUT. THEY'RE WEARING
THEM. PARDON NUMBER NINETEEN AB
FOURTEEN AGUIAR-CURRY VOTERS
CURRENTLY FORTY TWO.
ROBERT RIVAS. STILL. FOR TWO.
WHERE OTHER BILLS OUT. THE
BIBLE SAYS I KNOW YOU'RE- TIME
IS NOW UNDER THE OUT ONS. ABC
EIGHT SO. THE VOTE IS CURRENTLY
SIX ZERO LACKEY HI LACKEY I
BLOOM BLOOM I VOTERS. EIGHT
ZERO. FILLS OUT. AB NINE EIGHT
NINE THE VOTERS CURRENTLY SEVEN
ZERO LACKEY HI JACKIE I VOTE IS
CURRENTLY EIGHT ZERO BILLS HAVE.
WHICH IS THREE TWENTY. EIGHT
EIGHT THIRTY SIX THE VOTERS
CURRENTLY FOUR ZERO.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
HI RAMOS RAMOS I WILL THREE
LISTS WAS RIVERSIDE
ROBERT RIVAS. THE VOTE IS
CURRENTLY. SEVEN OH. SEVEN
ZERO. BILLS OUT A. B. THIRTY
SIX I'M SORRY WE HAVE THE NEXT
WAS CONSENT WE HAVE AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE. THE VOTE IS
CURRENTLY FIVE ZERO BLOOM. HI
HELLO I RAMOS RAMOS I'D THE
VOTE IS SIX ZERO. SEVEN ZERO
BILLS A. B. ELEVEN NINETY FIVE
MINUTES I DON'T DIRECT OR NOT
YES SHE DID. OKAY. WHAT WAS MY
BROKERAGE ADDED VOTED BY. AB
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE ELEVEN I'M A
VOTE CHANGE NOT BECAUSE I'M I
DON'T KNOW OKAY OKAY SO THAT'S
WHY I DIDN'T THINK I VOTED
BECAUSE IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ZERO. SHOULD BE NO YOU ME SO
THAT VOTE IS NOW SIX ONE. THANK
YOU. AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE IS
OUT SIX ONE. AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR GRAYSON. YEAH WE CAN WIN
AN ORDER TODAY SO THAT HAPPENS.
THE. WE DID THAT ONE OKAY WE'RE
GOOD ON THAT ONE THAT WAS THE
NUMBER EIGHT OKAY THAT'S
CORRECT WHEN DID WE COME OUT
WITH SOME OF THE PAULA JONES
ROAD THREE THREE NINE RIGHT NO
I KNOW BUT WHERE WAS THE GRAND
FINAL VOTE SORRY. SORRY. SEVEN
ZERO NUMBER HEY CANNOT DELIVER
SOLELY FOR HIS HELP. OKAY NOW
AB THREE THREE NINE LEE. KLAEBO
IS CURRENTLY FIVE ZERO LACKEY
NOT MONNING LUCKY NOT VOTING
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RUN LOS
ROBLES I. THE VOTE IS SEVEN
ZERO. AB THREE THREE NINE SIX
OUT SEVEN ZERO. SB FIVE SEVENTY
ONE MAYES VOTERS CURRENTLY SIX
ZERO LACKEY. HI BLACKIE I
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH AND THE VOTE IS
EIGHT ZERO. A. B. THE FIVE
SEVENTY ONE IS NOT A ZERO. AB
TEN TWENTY NINE MOLAND WHAT IS
CURRENTLY FIVE ONE LACKEY NOPE
LACKEY NOW. BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH OKAY THE VOTE
IS SIX TWO. K. BILLS SOUND THAT
WAS. TEN TWENTY NINE. AB SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT IN THIS AREA. LARA
ALWAYS DONE THAT'S RIGHT SORRY.
IN. SEVENTEEN TEN SEVENTEEN
MMHM. THREE DINNERS AREA READY.
THREE TEN SEVENTEEN WE DID
RIGHT YES OKAY SO WE ARE ON A.
B. THIRTEEN OH FOUR CORRECT
WAIT A MINUTE I DIDN'T VOTE ON
A TEN SEVENTEEN RIGHT WE
HAVEN'T GOT TEN SEVEN TWELVE
I'M SORRY I'M NOT PAYING
ATTENTION BECAUSE NOT HEARING
I'M SORRY AB TEN SEVENTEEN THE
VOTERS CURRENTLY FOR ONE LUCKY
I'M LUCKY- BLOOM. BLUE ALL
RIGHT ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS
ARE THE BOAT IS SEVEN ONE MAYBE.
TEN SEVENTEEN OUT SEVEN ONE. AB
THIRTEEN OH FOR THE VOTERS
CURRENTLY FOR ONE LACKEY- I
LACKEY I BLOOM. LOOK I ROBERT
RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS ALL RIGHT
VOTE IS. SEVEN ONE- BILLS OUR
THIRTY FORTY HOURS SEVEN ONE.
AB THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
VOTERS CURRENTLY FIVE ZERO
BLOOM. I WILL I BOERNER HORVATH.
BERHARAP NOT VOTING THE VOTE IS.
FIVE ZERO ZERO SIX ZERO. I'M A
NO BY THE WAY. MISSING LACKEY
WRECKED THE NUMBER. I WASN'T
HERE YEAH THANK YOU ARE SO
LUCKY SO THAT'S NOW FIVE ONE.
THE VOTERS FIVE ONE OKAY SO LET
ME JUST CLARIFY AB THIRTEEN
NINETY EIGHT IS FIVE ONE GROSS
OUT. BOERNER HORVATH AND
LOCALES NOT VOTING THANK. AB
EIGHT OH THREE THE VOTERS
CURRENTLY SIX ZERO LACKEY. HI
LET THE AYE ROMMEL'S AYE
STRUGGLES AYE THE BOAT IS EIGHT
ZERO HEY. SB ZERO THREE ZERO
TWO ZERO AB FOUR CHAIN THE VOTE
IS CURRENTLY FOR TWO. RIVAS HI
RIVAS I. THE VOTE IS FIVE TWO
BILLS OUT THANK THE LORD. YOUR
VOTER WHICH ONE. ALL TWO
THOUSAND CONSENT. YES SO THAT'S
WHAT. DURING EVERYBODY. GOOD
YES THANK YOU EVERYONE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR VOTE THANK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. LOCAL ADJOURNED.